welcome to Las Vegas and this is a gg33
production today we got an All-Star cast
let's get it started first Pearl she's
been everywhere
thank you for having me thank you for
coming
making his podcast debut debru what's up
brother what's up brother glad to be
here appreciate it and last but not
least Malik Obama this is basically
American royalty over here how you doing
today brother not bad pretty good so you
listen guys we got an All-Star cast here
I'm gonna go right into it man
um when we look at what's going on in
today's society what is the biggest
freaking issue to me it's feminism Pearl
to me it's women voting which is a
result exactly I think the root of all
evil was when they just gave us whatever
we wanted you know and now it's like you
have all these politicians that can't
get elected unless the women have a say
and it's like Democratic Democrats yeah
well that's well that's neither of them
I've even talked to Republicans that say
they lost an election because they they
need to get this women are swing voters
or men it's funny men are more loyal
even in party
it's like we can't
let's give them whatever they want and
let's let them vote and that was the
root of all evil I keep telling people I
keep telling people their 19th amendment
was way worse than 19. yeah take that
away take that [__] away immediately The
Brew what's your thoughts on feminism
man I think the I think we're looking at
the peak of the sexual inversion I think
men are becoming the gender lines are
extremely blurred men are obviously
becoming more like women women are
becoming more like men
I could chop this up for an hour
specifically on the just the the things
I've ascertained about it but yeah the
culture is 100 the gender lines are very
muddied right now and I think that women
are experiencing a lot of the things
that men have experienced over the past
hundred years Malik uh you live in Kenya
and America obviously America is the
best country in the world but but when
you come here you must see some crazy
that you don't see in Kenya brother
yeah it's like uh Star Trek deep deep
deep State you know so crazy over here
you know I'm telling you but uh right
now you know the main thing is to keep
it real you know and call it as it is
you know it's blurry stuff you can't be
all that you want to be because either
you're a man or a woman and that's it
but you can't have like
you don't know what you are you know so
I'm into like the reality you know and
that's how it is your your brother never
would have got elected without the
female vote I think what was it bro
about 61 percent of females voted for
Obama oh I don't know but I mean I I
heard that
every election would have been
Republican one if we just let them just
let the men know that's the whole point
because like this is what will happen
this is what they'll do they'll be like
oh here's a video of a 12 year old girl
that can't get an abortion this sad
story and we're so stupid we just start
running to the polls we're like oh my
God because women 12 year old we need to
go vote because women can be easily
emotionally manipulated yeah if I was
running the government to brute I want
Women Voters too too easy yeah sometimes
I want to run for an office just to take
that [__] away and step down because
women shouldn't be in politics they
shouldn't be impossible why would you
want a woman deciding for who World War
III like why do you want a woman with
the nuke button she's gonna she's gonna
get her period and then be like oh my
god well how about that that country
said something about me world war three
well would it be okay for a woman to be
elected if she is going through
menopause because you know I remember
you know when I was younger I I felt I I
used to see judges quite often when I
was young especially with my 20s and a
lot of these judges were females and I
was always thinking Matt I hope it's not
that time of the month because this
[__] is gonna ring me up and you know I
was I was you know you see like one guy
get rung up before you another guy get
rung up before you and then you're like
oh man when we're in menopause we're
crazy too
it's like you've never seen like a woman
going through menopause it's like they
lose their minds my mother maybe yeah
I mean not take I just think I just
think the root of all evil was when they
said to women that you can you're
equally as capable of making decisions
as men
I think that was the root of all evil
because it was a lie it's not true
um Malik
in Kenya are these women running around
demanding this and that like they do in
entitled America
not before but right now yes because now
we're in the this new age oh so they're
Americanized over there too they're
trying to oh they want to get their bag
from the man too over there now huh
culturally traditionally and um
the Customs out there won't allow it so
it's like unnatural and it's something
really really uh strange but the piles
all these uh in the world bank and uh
wherever they are who's trying to run
the show you know it's trying to make
everybody you know toe the line and then
make homosexuality legal which is oh
that ain't gonna happen in Africa is it
yeah that ain't gonna happen in Africa
I'll go there Malik I will go to your
country and make and protest against it
I'll be like listen when it comes to
homosexuality don't listen to the white
man no one ever listen to white man on
that garbage because that's what they
promote I honestly thought 10 years ago
it was a white man disease
I really thought that's what it was
because it was just spreading but now I
understand it's an agenda and they start
pushing this stuff in schools let me ask
you something
um
how many wives are you allowed to have
in Kenya in Africa There's No Limit you
know what would you say you can have as
many as you want so you could have four
five six seven as many as you want
that's just your traditionally custom
according to custom that's how it is but
in Islam you can only have four I see
okay so when it comes down to you how
many wives have you had sir it's a bit
personal I'm not gonna say okay they
come and go they come and go
I'm gonna go Gary I've been rotating in
theory about homosexuality that I think
is kind of avant-garde not too many
people have explored this but I
genuinely think this is true I think the
onslaught of homosexuality is stemming
from the dating Market is so steep it's
so competitive now to lock down a truly
good woman
what is the only community in the world
who will accept you for who you are no
matter how disgusting portly fat
corpulent doesn't matter how ugly and
grotesque you are you can get [__] in
the gay community without any
credentials you don't need any resume
you will find someone to get laid so you
can be the most grotesque Loser on
planet Earth and the gay community will
accept you there's no standards in the
gay community and I do believe a lot of
men are abandoning their posts and go in
AWOL and going into the gay community
simply because it's that tough on the
heterosexual side you're telling me you
think that there's a lot of gay men in
the world right now because they can't
get some [__] 100 I think they're
exploring I think their porno brain
first of all I think porn absolutely is
a gateway to homosexuality because your
dopamine is so torched and so fried I
mean look at Charlie Sheen Charlie Sheen
was banging hookers every day for years
he couldn't he could no longer get an
orgasm unless he started sucking dick
that's that's literally the Gateway so I
do think men are demanding their boasts
and being very experimental in this
community because this community will
accept you for who you are no matter
what kind of blemishes you have on your
record in the heterosexual Community we
know there's power dynamics you cannot
Escape
being somebody as a man to get a good
wife
yeah well you even seated in prison like
I've seen I've seen interviews of guys
that said they were straight when they
went into prison and they adopt I mean
like arguably sex is a need for men so
if they don't get it from women it's
like defense mechanism yeah like I
wonder what percent of gay people would
be gay if they had like the opportunity
to date a model I think a lot of people
in today's society might be gay because
they're raised by single mothers they
didn't have any masculine energy around
it I think I think that's probably the
biggest thing because if you look at it
oh there's so many more single mothers
today and I believe there's a lot more
gay people today it looks like a
correlation to me obviously they're
still pushing this garbage in the school
system brainwashing people and by the
way women bought that up Hook Line
they're just dummies we're idiots that's
why the government loves you yeah like
and I I've tried to like like not come
to this conclusion until I just saw the
things like as a collective we were like
voting for I was like we have had so
much choice in the last hundred years
we've like had more choice we could be
anything and we've chosen to be [__]
[__] one out of 25 of us under 35 are
on only fans and I didn't only fans and
I didn't even include women that accept
like um Instagram sex only only imagine
this and zurica brought this up on a
podcast only four percent of us are
virgins on our wedding days all we had
to do all we had to do was think
wait till 22 21 go get like a Saudi
Prince you're a virgin but none of us
thought of that we're idiots oh you
could have got a big bad I know I didn't
think of it could you imagine girls I
heard I heard something keep your legs
closed and you get paid ladies I know
it's like we're dummies I heard
something that made me laugh recently
they said any any time a woman sleeps
with a partner before marriage that's
her cheating on her future husband I
agree it's true yeah
that's true um it's all manufactured you
know because naturally and traditionally
uh
people are just sleeping around not
really you know
they had to you know
get married first and fornication really
is for married couples oh what what
about uh your brother Barack
oh I can't say was he a ladies man
before you get with Michelle
well when I first met him he was with
the uh
Sheila Sheila yeah there's a lady called
Sheila Sheila sounds like a cartoon
character I'm
sorry what's not like some kind of like
He-Man Shiro or something like that I'm
going flashback to the age some lady so
yeah I guess so she was a lady though
she was a lady okay okay well we're
cooking now so what else was
[Music]
looks like she has a contract for as a
lineman for the Chicago Bears I haven't
seen her in a long time so what's the
last time you saw the show Michelle
20.
2009 2009 at the inauguration okay you
were at her wedding in 92 yeah and then
you were over there in 2009 yeah and
that's 17 years did she become a
bodybuilder like how did she put up hook
up like so much mass you tell me I don't
know well I mean this is your field
brother how does a woman who I mean she
looked like she was about 135 140 pounds
in her wedding date how does she look
like a linebacker now is that possible
linebacker Pro Bowl
a brighter lacker huh it's got a four
240. I mean all jokes aside I mean
that's a scary [__] she's got a video
taper she loses weight she adds weight
so I don't know she's just like
amorphous is she taking steroids in your
opinion 100 I don't know she's on
anabolics games something going on there
I don't know what it is she's running
the Holy Trinity HGH deca little test
base little anavar for why would she why
would you do that
does not like look bad it's got to be
some kind of cultural programming right
listen
that picture you showed me and um you
know we'll put it up we start doing
clips that you showed me of Michelle
Obama at her wedding she looked like a
woman to me yeah sure she looked like a
straight woman when you met Michelle
Obama in 1992 she looked like a woman
correct yes she did yeah she was felt I
saw pictures of her she was felt she was
live walking through the room petite
yeah now her delts are bigger than mine
how how is that possible for a woman
a lot of strange things going on now
maybe it's not her maybe
okay so is it possible in your
um
opinion that the Michelle Obama we're
seeing right now is not the same
Michelle Obama that you saw in 1992. it
could be anything because everything's
staged now now world's the stage
everything's stage now you don't know
what's real and what's not real you know
that's why I'm talking like pills
talking about nobody knows like a woman
is this a real woman you don't know if
you're with a woman or with a man
because the lines you don't know well I
know I know because I checkbooks have
you have you ever heard of that guy that
was drugging women on dates by putting
Viagra in their drinks just to make sure
what has the world cup too he's like I
just wanted to double check right now
you don't know what's going on you know
you don't know do you have transsexuals
in Kenya
shoes yeah one or two I mean like
they're bad but are they they don't go
around flaunting it I see so you don't
have ABT parades in Kenya they're trying
to do all that but it's against the law
you know so Kenya is is it Kenya more of
a Christian or a Muslim country it's
it's mixed mixed it's mixed okay so so
the Christians are going to bend the
knee like they do here in America today
uh I don't see the Muslims doing it no
they're trying to brainwash everybody
and try and get it like this
new world world order the people are
trying to control everything they're
trying to make things in such a way that
you don't know what's whether it's you
can see it's a Pepsi but they're trying
to tell it's a Coca-Cola
you're pretty critically correct my back
that's what they're trying to do you
know they're playing and messing around
with everybody's mind it's the power of
repetition
if you try to be real and natural
they're trying to make that
abnormal so everything is like oh so if
you have a family if you take care of
your kids if you have a housewife that
you take care of that's abnormal you're
the [__] up one right that's right ah
see I I got it now yeah it all makes
sense now so they're trying to flip
everything what your brother wants to do
that's what he's doing he's like he's a
he's like a what do you call an octopus
you don't know where he stands he's
standing is you know he's trying to
please everybody you know you can't go
around pleasing everybody you got to
make a stand you got to have a spine and
your brother does not have a spine no
he's up to it you know whatever is gonna
make him you know uh uh stand out you
know
last time I talked to you in uh Miami
was around May of this year and I told
you that I believe that
um Barack Obama is going to start going
after Joe Biden since that interview in
May countless scandals with Hunter Biden
and Joe Biden have been released to the
Press
your brother's going for him but
there is a body found
right by Obama his personal chef
how does Obama's personal chef die
on Martha's Vineyard
how does that happen you ever been there
no I don't know like right now in Hawaii
Hawaii is burning and I haven't heard
him say a thing about it and that's
where he was born oh so you don't give a
[__] I don't think he does he's like
just doing something out there and
trying to figure him out and he's not
the person that I knew
he's changed uh well when you hold
ankles that's what happens uh de Bru let
me ask you something when I start saying
that the personal chef for Barack Obama
was found dead on Martha's Vineyard what
comes to your head what is it the
clintons sending messages to oh boy what
do you think something like that is yeah
I mean Foul Play immediately comes to
mind of course
Pearl
I don't know anything about that
I don't know maybe see this is this is
exactly what we need we need women to be
like that oh I don't know anything about
politics I don't care anything about
politics if that happens the world will
be a much better place I promise you
that
um yeah my only politics is women
shouldn't vote that's my biggest
politics sorry
you know and I honestly let me ask you
this bro if men go out there and say
we will provide certain
benefits for women do you think it's a
whole they'll give up their right to
vote if say that
no I don't think we'll ever give it up
because we already get a bunch of Rights
we could really get a bunch of
privileges we're paid to be single
mothers yeah we're we're paid to leave
marriages we also get paid if we stay
married it's like and California don't
even have to get married six months live
in the same place you can start suing
the guy for child support yeah exactly
so it's like it's like what what more do
we need we have everything you can go
work you can go not work you can go live
off the government you can go live off
of man it's like what what else do we
need and what do we still do we whine we
whine and that's what I realized I'm
like we just are big whiners like we
just are never happy
I don't know why you can never satisfy a
woman yeah it's unfortunate it just
seems to be our nature I don't know I
just did a video on this corporate land
is dominated by women it's done phone it
in man I don't think job the job space
is even a viable market for men anymore
I truly don't I think it's all dominated
by women corporate corporate
corporations are headed in that
direction but my point in stating that
is that there's two there's really only
two sectors left of men in my opinion
who can even find a wife and it's it's
this is controversial but it's losers
and the rich
losers have access to women because in
my opinion uh there's a low anxiety you
know what I mean like
there's a certain income spread right
now that is very hard for men in the
dating market and that spread in my
opinion is between like 140 to 250 000 a
year income those guys are invisible
they're they're not rich but they have
the kind of jobs that are just hard
enough to where there's no women around
so they're they're having such a tough
time and a lot of these guys computer
geeks 100 The Tech Guys and I have
access to this Market because these are
the guys who follow me on Twitter
and they all lament to me over and over
again that as soon as they got on their
feet and got these higher paying jobs
their dating Market completely dried up
it's drier than the Sahara they cannot
find women when they were losers they
said they were cleaning up and I think
are they going for higher quality women
now though I think they are oh yeah
that's probably why that's probably why
but I do think that in this culture
that's inverted the ambition of a man
who works out routinely is super
shredded jacked Rich it's it yells
anxiety
and I think that that is what's putting
these women off subliminally I think
that women like low anxiety men which is
why I think the loser archetype for for
whatever reason does do well in this
kind of Market is it's only the loser if
he's hot though right you're telling an
ugly loser yes [__] that's that's
fair that's true okay that's true um and
then but then they talk about how like
gold diggers and I'm like
how do you bash a gold digger in my eyes
that makes zero sense because you mean
to tell me that a woman likes you for
something that you earned rather than
the way that you were born like that's
how it should be a woman should be into
you based on what you've earned in this
life so the whole women coming after
your mother they're going to be loyal
though if you find a woman when you
actually have a big bag a high
percentage of them are not going to be
loyal if you find a woman when you're
broke you bond together you grow
together she's probably not going to
cheat on you when you have the bag but
that's if you take the nerd root if you
take the nerd root like Elon elon's
worth 230 billion can't lock down a
woman still jerking off about Grimes
true but I do think life experience is
what bleeds over look and I've said this
on Spaces before I do believe the single
thing that a woman wants the most in a
man subliminally and I've never heard
anybody else say this but me I think
ultimately a woman wants to know that
she can not fool or befuddle you she
can't pull one over on you you see her
coming a mile away you put it in check
she she has to know for sure she cannot
pull the wool over your eyes and
anything you know when she's lying you
know when she's being sneaky you just
know you can Telegraph it that only
comes from life experience that doesn't
come from business a lot of these rich
crypto kids who are nerds who became
very wealthy they're struggling because
they skipped the Life part you got to be
in the trenches as a man suffering pain
you got to learn you got to learn Life
got to get your heart broken a couple
times that's the root of a man once you
kind of build that scar tissue and you
have that experience it translates over
and you become a gamer then it's the
first you get played then you become a
player correct 100 okay that seems
logical
um Pro anything to say no I agreed with
him um I would have said guidance but
it's like the same thing like the same
thing yeah yeah it's like no because
when you are looking at a guy you kind
of want to see it's like can can he
guide me 100 yeah 100 and I think a lot
of these younger guys don't understand
that you have to teach all the time like
that being in a long-term relationship
is the most it's life on Hardcore Mode
it is the hardest difficulty saying and
especially like with us like a bunch of
women like we even like most women
aren't raised to be wives right like
even even women that like came from two
parent households it's like what percent
of men lead relationships what percent
of people have traditional relationships
you know there's an entire and like what
I think a third of people were born in
single parent households now it depends
depending on the demographics much
higher yeah yeah depending on them
demographics yeah but so that's what I
mean when I say guidance because half of
half of guys don't even like they don't
even know that you know no they can't
even get that part down at all yeah
don't communicate don't sit down don't
teach you have to explain things the the
computer has done a lot to destroy men's
ability to actually know how to talk to
women 100 I had I remember
um you know having get-togethers in
Vegas inviting a whole bunch of people
and you would see women sitting at the
bar
and guys playing video games
and I'm like you know I'm married and
everything so I can't really do anything
about looking at these women like I'm
sorry I feel bad for you I don't know
what else to tell you you know playing
video games when you have women around
who are basically trying to you know get
to know you and stuff like that I think
these guys don't know how to talk to
women and you know 10 15 years ago I
would have laughed at the idea of a
coach that tells you know guys how to
you know get women I would have laughed
at that hitch concept now it's a viable
Market but yeah we also lost Community I
think you know what I mean like people
used to have like friend groups or you'd
meet like the guy down the hall you know
the poor you know your neighbors and
stuff like that yeah yeah that's what I
mean so like you know maybe a guy that
didn't know how to talk I hate my
neighbor by the way
do it but you know like I don't know any
of the Neighbors in my building or in
London like I don't know I know all the
neighbors that have a trump sign in
their front yard those are the ones I go
when I say hi you do doing those are the
ones I want to break bread with
um and basically what you have to
understand is
people are very stupid I'm just gonna
flat out say it and it doesn't matter
where you are in the world people are
very ignorant and one of the biggest
reasons is because people don't get
breastfed anymore
fact when kids get breastfed their IQs
go up nine to ten percent higher so when
the woman actually stayed at home when
men were men and they actually had
enough money to provide for the family
all of a sudden these kids had higher
IQs people wonder why all these people
are stupid now no one's getting
breastfed and then you have tenacious
life forms like myself they can get half
and half and still turn out all right oh
there you go brother but like you're the
exception to the rules it's 100 true
though I think the breastfeeding the
breastfeeding thing is insane to me
because how did Gerbers like that is the
greatest marketing campaign ever how did
Gerbers hijack the female amygdala and
convince them or dummies that [__]
Zog slop
is more potent and powerful and
nourishing than your own breast that's a
marketing campaign women got Bamboozled
in what the 70s 80s that's that's just
completely yeah they completely
abdicated their feminine instinct to
Gerbers yeah that makes zero [__]
sense to me how the power enforces in
play on that I mean we pick we pick
husbands I'm sorry
your horoscope signs I mean that's how I
did it look at we look at magazines like
I I think what you do is a little more
complex than what the average chick does
oh yeah that's a good point it's like
I'm just saying like this is you know
not character not not like what it's
it's you know it was amazing Pro when I
uh first started getting into numerology
astrology
um I went to all the top numerologists
all the top astrologers in 2002 and
there was a common theme
woman divorced three four times uh and I
kept asking these women if you're so
good at astrology why'd you get divorced
three or four times uh people grow apart
but you didn't see that coming and you
know just to put in perspective I've
been married for almost 20 years so
obviously I knew what the hell I was
doing but other people they just don't I
mean you know Malik when it comes to
your country are men having similar
issues like they do in America they
can't find a good woman I mean obviously
you don't have that problem no in Africa
traditionally it's arranged you know so
like by the time the woman gets to the
age of puberty
she's married off so we're off we could
go so it's not like you know any any
woman who's not married after that age
is just whoring around you know so wait
a second if a woman isn't married by
what age 20 22. well when she starts you
know like experiencing uh you know both
yeah well they can sometimes give birth
to 13 14. what's that so they're married
off because at 13 14. I'm just saying
that because like what it is the
culturally over there if a woman gives
birth birth like she was saying that
most women now not virgins you know
they've been sleeping around you know
yeah so at the end of the day you know
to get a good woman who hasn't been
sleeping around you know you have to
catch them before they get you know get
going
so uh they get married off
do you think do you think and when you
think that's a superior system to what
is going on here in America I I think so
yes less divorce
and they don't get divorced because at
that time you know that age she's not
you know corrupted
so she's gonna go into the marriage you
know
are ready for it Pearl you're looking
for an arranged marriage it was funny
when I was younger I would always say
but my parents could do an arranged
marriage they never took me up on it
though
um Gary I actually want someone to
challenge me on this because there's
something I've been thinking about go
ahead
um I've been begging for someone to
challenge me on this one
um the whole body count thing I get it
and it's fundamental form I understand
why it's atrocious right however I do
think women are by far the more
malleable sex
it's not even close I think women that
are damaged abused traumatized Etc I
think have a much higher chance of
restoration than men who are dramatized
and the reason I think that is because
any time you see
a woman get into a relationship with an
extremely powerful male that she
respects and reveres
all of that [__] Behavior literally
disappears I've seen it over and over
again I do believe women can be restored
by powerful men
um why would they want to why would you
want to restore a [__] [__] when you
know there's so many other women who
basically haven't been through the
trenches like they have as a man
um I would be repulsed if a woman had a
high body count repulsed yes but I think
part of the male Instinct of wielding
that power is understanding that you can
actually take a broken woman I'm not
talking about being [__] Captain Save
A Hoe that's not what I'm talking about
I'm just talking about finding a woman
that you want to invest in because let's
be real and here's why I'm coming to
this conclusion if you look at every
wealthy athlete even the billionaires
why is no but why are none of the people
who have the means and the power why are
none of them exploring this Utopia
virgins I don't see that in practice I
see it in theory in the real world that
I live in all the athletes are competing
with all the Instagram Horrors that have
a huge amount of body counts because
those women inner experience they're fun
they're more attractive it seems to me
that all the exclusively are they
marrying those [__] they're not
marrying them but they're but they're
where is the Virgin Utopia they're not
around anymore that's what I'm saying
they're just not around that's exactly
what I'm saying so like he said in the
beginning it's almost like you do it
young or not at all it seems like these
days fair enough likely you get married
young that's why I always say it if
churches aren't actively like setting
people up they're really just pushing
promiscuity because what's the option
most people like most people aren't
going to wait till what 21 22. like so
if you're not pushing early marriage
what's the other alternative but that's
my question we as we still have to play
the game right as men we still have to
play the game we're dealt cards right
now this is the landscape this is the
culture what do we do we got to play our
hands right and even a hundred years ago
85 percent of women said they were
virgins so like even if they're lying
right and like it's two out of three
that's still the majority right because
these women were ashamed
I know but I'm saying like like now
nowadays only four percent of women are
virgins so he's saying adapt to the
market 100 like so I'm saying like 96 of
us would have been thrown out 100 years
ago okay that's how that's how crazy
like everything's like I mean I would
have been burned at the stake for being
a numerologist astrologer 200 years ago
you know would have been impaled on
antler bones hey brother [__] ancient
Greece so would I
yeah it's it you know as much [__]
as we talk about as ever as much as
everything is wrong in the world let's
face it guys since the 1940s uh
Humanities had been on a good run man
Humanity's been on a good run we've
actually had more well-run ever best you
know we've had a lot of wealth and the
problem is these women now have their
own money and because they have their
own money they believe they don't need a
mad and once in their when they're in
their 20s 30s that might work but once
they hit that 40 and I can't tell you
the number of women I've given
numerology readings to who were you know
in their 40s 45 they have no kid
obviously the cat at the house and they
keep telling me I got Bamboozled I got
van Boozled and what I'm trying to tell
you young women out there is don't get
played you just saw what they did with
you just saw how they played the world
with covid never trust the government
especially if you're a woman because
they just want to destroy your life they
want you to be a leech on society they
want you to have a whole bunch of kids
out of wedlock because those kids are
not going to have masculine figures and
what happens when kids don't have
mascara figures they become criminals
because no one checks them when they're
young
85 percent
85 of rapists were raised by single
mothers you [__] feminists want to
talk about [__] you're the ones who are
[__] bringing the [__] rapists
you're doing this you know that's what I
seriously I went for months I was like
is there anything women are better at
and I came to this conclusion that men
must just be superior beings because
we're more likely to kill the infants
and the elderly that's literally the one
thing we're supposed to be is nurturing
I couldn't believe it and then I found
out all the world's problems basically
happen when we raise kids so I was like
unless we're under the authority of men
we just kind of suck
I Can't Describe like it's like I mean
I'm not saying we can't be great but
it's literally only under the authority
of men because like what what happens
when we're left to our own devices we
just suck it's 100 true that's why I've
said ambition I think is a feminine
trait because women are the ambitious
ones women need to project their
Authority onto a tall charismatic
handsome man right that's that's the
archetype to in order to push their
agenda right
in a common household now even guys with
money it's the women coming to the
husband hey I wanted you to start a
[__] Bakery right even if it loses
10K a month he's like baby have fun go
lose go torch 10K a month have fun with
your bakery women are constantly trying
to advance an agenda through projecting
their Authority onto a man now the man
has the ability to strike that down
right or not but I do believe that that
the the ethos of ambition is a feminine
trait in the mod in the modern society
ambition is a feminine trait I will die
on that so if I have an ambition to
become president United States that's
feminine it's so here's the thing the
drive the anima inside the man because
there's masculine feminine that's right
every hyper masculine man has an
extremely feminine core I believe that
to be an absolute fact
um yes I believe there's a woman driving
that man deep inside 100 I will agree in
the sense that almost every man I've
ever met who's a baller I mean you know
not [__] gold chains all over but a
legitimate 100 million billionaire
um most of them have a very good woman
on their side I will tell you that
absolutely
um I it's very important for men to
actually have a loyal woman let me tell
you why
as a man you can't go out there and
Conquer you can't go out there and be
the best version of yourself if you're
worried your girl is going to be sucking
someone else's dick when you're out when
you're gone you can't do it 100 I mean
unless you're Destiny 100 you know that
line in that rap song hoes ain't loyal I
think that's completely inverted I think
women are the loyal ones I If a woman
truly loves a man I am I kid you not you
think it's your boys who will bury a
body in the desert for you it's actually
your girl your girl a woman will go
under barbed wire and climb [__]
Mount Everest naked for you if she's in
love with you I have never seen loyalty
on this Earth from any creature any
Beast than a woman that's the truth
I've had plenty of male loyalty but the
the female loyalty once it's locked in
is unlike any other thing maybe maybe
with you maybe with you we're talking
about outliers maybe with you and I I
gotta say um you know when it comes down
to it if you're [__] a woman right
she's probably not going to leave you
100 you know that's what it all comes
down to they need that in their life too
yeah but but a woman would rather be the
king's concubine than the peasant's wife
so she's leaving the peasant for the
king
yeah women women who have rules will
break them for certain guys that that
I've seen there's a reason 40 of men
don't have kids and only 14 of women
don't have kids and and that's why we
had the institution of marriage that's
why we actually had religion so that 40
percent of losers could have women could
have wives that's why the institution of
marriage was created so we could have
they could have kids a society but now
it's all destroyed and it's all
destroyed because of feminism because
these women now will run around do
whatever they want and they have no
accountability I mean accountability in
women just go to hand in hand like oil
and water okay but this is where the red
pill goes wrong let's go super wrong
right red pill tells you be toxic be
unavailable don't be around too much got
to be with your boys leave her at home
leave her at home garbage advice and
I'll tell you why
in the 1950s if a woman was chilling at
home there was no cultural programming
that was that corrosive if she turns on
the TV what's going to be on the TV
Little House on the Prairie Lassie not
that bad right now if you leave a woman
at home long term for too long
what's the cultural program she's going
to be scrolling Instagram Facebook
absolutely corrosive toxic corrosive
programming right so it's going to fry
her brain 100 if she's left unchecked I
think it's the complete opposite I think
men need to be in the game very often
with their woman in 2023 I think you
need to be around her all the time I
think she should be like the pet monkey
on your shoulder everywhere you go
because
it's that projected Authority that I was
talking about you know what I mean men
can't always be around their women
they have to trust their woman it's
going to be loyal when they're out there
going out there across the country
making their bag 100 but I also do
believe that women need to look I think
the only relationships that work
nowadays is a woman needs to be in on
the project with her man should be
helping you secure the bag if your
woman's not helping you secure the bag
or not working with you on a project
there's a [__] problem in my opinion
there has to be an Incorporation
I mean to some degree listen if a woman
is working too much she starts stressing
out and she starts picking up masculine
traits yeah it's okay for your woman to
help you out a little bit but none of
this 50 50 people no no no no no no no
no no no no certainly not certainly not
the 50 50 thing but like I don't know
I've seen a trend of like women kind of
ruining their
husband's business I've seen like a
trend of like women thinking they're way
more important than they are and taking
all the credit for their husband's
success I I I've actually heard that one
before we're seeing this like trying
yeah so I don't know I could see both
sides but I definitely like some chicks
get in the business I'm not gonna say it
because I'm not trying to start drama
but I can think of one YouTube
personality that like the woman has made
their reputation so much worse
so much more I will agree if it comes to
a intelligent high value woman
but I mean intelligent women bro come on
you know I hate the middle you know I
hate talking about the middle I like
talking about the top I got you I got
you the people who are listening to you
are at the bottom at least most of them
but they're aspiring to be at the top I
get you I get you brother the thing that
I wanted to say too is I think you can
you can literally only be an alpha in
the streets or in the sheets you have to
pick one all the all the gangsters that
I know that are alpha in the streets
they're all on their wife's leash all of
them because they're away from home too
long and what happens is you whenever if
you look my point is is obviously you
can be away from the home but if you're
away from home for too long you
inevitably make mistakes that score her
a ton of points that's all I'm saying in
this modern day and age there's two look
you can almost say Instagram and social
media is a surrogate patriarchy right as
a man you now are pitted against enemies
that are trying to control and dominate
your women corporations everything is
pro trying to program your your woman so
where does the authority come from men
are losing authority to all these media
conglomerates
so how do you how do you step in and
squash that you got to be in the game
with her that's my point
of course you still have to answer the
call to Adventure as a male if you're a
red-blooded male yeah you got to scratch
that itch but me as a man I'm pitted
against [__] I got 20 guns pointed
at my head trying to program my woman on
a good day on a good day
and I gotta fight that somehow right the
only way to do that is to be sitting in
the throne I think the best way to do
that is make sure your woman doesn't
have any [__] friends who are a horse
that's I I think that's the number one
thing 100 correct I'm gonna tell you
right now if your girl tells you that
she's the good girl in the crew I got
news for you brother yeah yeah
um that's that's a fact so friends
should be vetted I think that's an
important conversation to have I think
friends need to be vetted 100 especially
men
who change on you as soon as they get a
woman
if you have if you've been boys with
someone for about 10 15 years and they
find a woman and all sudden in a month
they start flipping on you you know that
that and they start being disloyal and
more loyal to the woman after a month
that's why I would never have beta male
friends 100 because they will never
[__] be loyal to you they will
[__] sell you out the river as soon
as you can because if a man is easily
influenced by flesh if a man is weak to
flesh that means he's not going to be
loyal
he's just not he will sell you out for
the woman every single time I'll sell
you up for a Diet Coke at that that's
unfortunate
I can't even get a Coke in a glass
brother some Mexican Coke I mean what
the [__] this is run-of-the-mill Diet
Coke man I've seen it happen it's unreal
we'll do it Malik you've been hearing
this conversation did we just sound like
a whole bunch of [__] Americans too
now they've got a lot of good points
there and I'm just listening in
and trying to get my bearings
but I think that's the issue right now
is that you know where are your bearings
you know what are your principles you
know what how are you brought up you
know you know what a man is do you know
what a woman is
what's the duties what are your duties
you know what's a woman supposed to be
doing what's your wife supposed to be
doing what are you supposed to be doing
my wife's supposed to be watching the
kids I don't know what otherwise they're
doing my wife is so natural my wife's
supposed to be taking care of home
while you the man is out there you know
working
and coming and you take care of her and
she takes care of you by taking care of
home so you don't have to be worried
about what's going on in the back
yeah I mean 100 once we know what our
rules are what our Duties are then we're
okay but if we start you know saying
that okay like okay I can do what a
woman can do and while I'm you know and
a woman say yeah I can't do what a man
can do then the lines become blurry and
you don't know what's going on and
anything goes and that's where now we
don't know who's supposed to be in
control
is the man or is it the woman let's flip
the script don't check it hold on let's
flip the script for a second let's say
the woman is making a lot more money
than the man in relationship
is he not eventually going to be the
beta male [__]
100 but that's one of the most common
configurations right now that goes back
to my point about corporate land women
like if you if I'm not even joking if
you're goofy and you can [__] a woman
good right now a woman will take care of
you so buy you gifts take you on trips
she'll pay for everything you see these
configurations all over the place don't
you want that though [__] no I would
never want a [__] woman taking care
of me listen listen when I was broke
like in uh when I was 21 22 and I had to
you know like my girlfriend had to help
me out and stuff like that I felt like a
[__] dude I felt like a straight up
[__] and the problem is if you don't
have that self-worth in you if you don't
have those morals and you'd be like yo
this ain't the way I can't have this bra
taken care of me you know you're you're
not going to succeed in life that's at
least my opinion 100 but so my point was
the only two configurations that work
are the polar ends of that it's either
that configuration which is a common one
or you got to go the complete other
direction where you lowered over the
house like a [__] Aristocrat it's
literally one of the two so you either
be like Tate or be like a church
pretty much yeah The Middle's dusted
dude the middle is dusted people don't
understand the middle is so wrecked
right now it's at the extremes always
it's high and low in theory low end
dudes are cleaning up high-end dudes are
cleaning up the middle is completely
flat unless you're a woman unless if
you're a woman you're a five you can put
up some makeup go on IG look like a 7.5
all of a sudden these guys are offering
you trips yeah I mean I've seen
influencers talk to people on the phone
for uh on video call for the first time
on streams talking about yo come through
I'll buy you a ticket this and that I'm
like wow but that's that's part of the
inversion have you noticed that very
good looking men date very ugly women
I don't think women who are extremely
good looking want a man who looks better
that is correct that is correct that's
what a lot of these youngsters do not
understand is that so this is part of
the inversion you got a bunch of guys
who are looks maxing now if you notice
this guys are so self-conscious about
their appearance I I have a personal
theory that the invention of the mirror
like the household mirror is one of the
most evil [__] introductions into
culture because men started preening and
primping in front of the [__] mirror
and it created this gaping hole of
insecurity that has yet to be filled
men were never really supposed to know
what the [__] they looked like you know
what I mean like it you had to stoop low
into a [__] body of water to see your
reflection men are Salient forces we're
thrusters we're supposed to inflict what
we have inside us onto the world you
know what I mean like we're not supposed
to contain things in but this modern
society it's guys just want to be
prettier than their [__] girlfriend
have you noticed this guys literally
want to be more beautiful than their
[__] women I remember my dad told me
um the man's job is to work have scars
and the woman's jobs to look good I'm
I'm totally okay with my woman looking
good enough for the both of us I'm
totally okay with that exactly because
that that I don't I don't think men
should be pretty boys unless they're
five boy pads I don't think men should
be pretty boys dude it's a cursed
archetype actually seriously because
like like the incels should be a little
bit easier on themselves to be honest
with you because the the [__] pretty
boy archetype he might be able to [__]
100 chicks a week but he ain't any
closer to getting loved in the incel you
know what I mean because he's not a man
he's a pretty boy there's a huge
difference and you are correct 100
because like you said
a woman never wants a man to outshine
her in The Beauty Department I don't
know that is not what I've seen
um just from like interviewing guys on
shows the pretty boys clean up they
clean up but they don't get love no they
do like I mean all the pretty boys come
on and like some of the guys will be
complaining about like modern women
whatever and they're like I don't know
what you're talking about women cook for
me all the time they do yeah except
again women will make exceptions for
certain guys yeah you know a woman who's
never cooked before all of a sudden she
finds the man of her dreams she's in
their Betty Crocker all the time yeah I
mean maybe maybe that's what you've seen
I just haven't seen that yet well I mean
listen the way I look at it
um I think women are the most
manipulative creatures on the planet I
think if a woman is attractive
um and she can you know knows how to
just manipulate a little bit she can be
very [__] dangerous extremely
dangerous and you know listen if you're
a girl and you're one of these boss
girls and you know you're making your
money and you're doing your thing cool
as long as you're not who open your legs
to like 50 different men within two
years or something like that it's fine
because the problem with women is you
get pregnant and then you have those
kids
that's the issue
talking about micro chimerism yeah I
mean to a point I'm sure you could have
a field day with that huh micro
chimerism where women literally hosts
portions of the DNA of every man they've
ever slept but that DNA never goes never
change that's that's why women actually
absorb energy and Men actually give
energy that's what and again I'm not
saying men should be [__] either but
there's a difference if a man slept with
a hundred women and a woman slept with a
hundred men there's a difference women
absorb energy I always like to point out
that you know the word mentally ill
starts with men meaning if you sleep
with too many men you become mentally
ill all these [__] who are out here
[__] sleeping with 20 30 40 freaking
guys they're all bipolar I mean you all
know [__] every single one of you and
they're usually all bipolar because they
slept with too many guys and just like
you said that energy resonates oh one
there's one show where there's some only
fans chicks on and who said their body
count was like I don't know 50 to 100
something like that disgusting yeah I
know and freaking I remember feeling I
was like I feel like a demonic presence
and then there's one girl was like can
we be friends I'm like no
[__] I was like I'm blocking you after
this show
I'm like no I don't need this stay away
um
Gary have you noticed that have you
noticed this looks Maxine culture among
men like these bodybuilding types that
are so a lot of them seem like they're
gay 100 I mean I I've had these guys
attack me and then you go look on their
stream they're selling they're bragging
about selling photos to gay men and
saying gay men pay a lot of money for
photos it's like wow oh my gosh I had a
guy in the show that did only fans like
gay stuff like he he said he was gay for
pay
I mean I think that just makes you gay
but he's definitely straight listen
listen if you're holding your ankles
you're gay I don't give a damn how
masculine you think you are I don't give
a damn about any of this stuff
um it's it's a totally degenerate
Society what are some solutions besides
repealing 19 which we're both for what
are some solutions is there any other
way to like take women's vote away well
one okay I I also I feel like men are
taking a pay cut I I can't prove this
but I really think they're like
subsidizing women's jobs because I don't
really think we do all that much in the
workforce like we just go to HR and just
wine that's really all we do we let go
you remember those tick tocks of those
girls like working at tech companies and
they're like I had like two meetings
today and these girls all made like six
figures in Tech so to me it's similar to
the WNBA where they take the men's money
and give it to the women I think we need
to get rid of all these diversity hires
I just think it's [__] I think
because it inflates our ego and makes us
think we're more important than we are
you know what's interesting about that
fact the WNBA makes a lot less money
than NBA and they actually take their
money from the NBA but here's the
interesting part women [__] [__] [__]
there's more women in America than men
if they actually supported women the
same way men support men when they come
to Athletics they'd be making the same
amount of money if not more let's not
forget Ronda Rousey was the number one
UFC fighter it would pay for a long time
yeah not because she was a woman but
because she was the number one
attraction and that's the beautiful
thing about capitalism if you bring in
the money they will give you the money
well and that's and that's what what I
realized was that I was looking at
because I played women's sports my whole
life so I realized I was like basically
all the men are taking a pay cut I mean
they don't get asked if they want to but
they really are like all the NBA players
are taking a pay cut and giving it to
the women and what I realized I'm like I
bet you the same Dynamic is going on in
Corporate America I think the men are
just getting paid less and they're
working more that's what that's what I
think is happening and because I I
looked at infrastructure jobs I'm like
because a lot of times we [__] on the
average guy and I think sometimes it's
just like well we need the average men
in order to do what we do none of us can
do what we do without the men running
the infrastructure of society and so my
question is I started I expanded the
definition of infrastructure a little
bit to include like truckers to include
you know trans because you know some
people say it's just Plumbing
electricity but I expanded it slightly
but 45 percent of men means one out of
two men have infrastructure jobs where
less than seven percent of women have
infrastructure jobs and and the women
that do it's like two percent of them
are police do those really count like
that get the [__] out of there and so
it's like my question is why are we
making more under 30 if the men are
doing the more important jobs like we
always talk about these like you know
lonely lost men and I and I agree but
that's like what's causing this and I
think it's a lot of them are really
frustrated because I really think
they're working more they're taking the
money from the men giving it to the
women to give us these goddamn stupid
egos making us feel so special when
really they're the ones doing the hard
jobs I can't disagree with them and even
I was thinking about this like you know
I do well but am I really like you know
I make a lot of money for someone my age
but would you put up with a man who made
less than you well I have to I mean come
on like I mean I'm good no no you don't
no but it's like it'll be more difficult
for you yeah no but it's just like the
way I look at it is like okay my
brothers are Engineers they're smarter
than me they make less than me but my
brothers are only fans girls make a
million a month yeah the guys behaving
the road and making 50 000 a year right
has nothing to do with intellect but
that's my my point is like just because
you make more than a guy like it's just
me monetizing beauty that doesn't really
count as being smart I mean I I do think
I'm smart you know for a woman not for a
man but but but in all honesty it's like
I listen to my brothers all the time
they make less than me like I just I you
know I know guys will never believe me
but I've always I've always wanted to
date an engineer well I mean I'm sure
millions of people are going to watch
this they're gonna be right in your DMs
bro we get one of those arranged
marriages yeah right well this is this
is what I'm trying to get at though
we're kind of returning to Primal times
now or it's like the the male lines are
relatively lazy just chilling like
serious I think we're riding the decline
until the wheels come off men I don't
know any I can literally can name a
handful of people that I know that are
working hard in America right now
I don't know too many people that are
working that hard men are pretty lazy
we're just chilling sunbathing doing
whatever the [__] we do the women are
out hunting getting the food like to
bring
were they hunting what are we were they
hunting I see it I mean it's like you
know no not hunting men they're hunting
resources that's what I'm saying women
are working men are resources to women
yeah but sex work is like more a more
common profession than education now
like that's one that's one of the number
one employers of women is education
enough you're probably better at it too
that's what I'm saying they're logging
more hours at the computer than the guys
are but no they're not the guys
are clicking a couple buttons trading
crypto all day no they're not not the
majority if you look up the break the
breaking down the workforce no they're
not again 45 of men have infrastructure
jobs so that means you're like driving
the trucks that's not an easy job the
electricity that's not an easy job like
I mean men run how do we get no but but
that SEC those sectors are fading no of
course they are they're slowly
disappearing that is true I mean yeah
but still but I'm saying like to right
now 45 of men have infrastructure jobs
where only seven percent of women do and
I I don't think women work more than men
and you can look at that even the income
over a lifetime it starts to Peak after
we hit 30. it starts to like um Flatline
for women 80 of the debt in this country
is by women yeah well and women women so
it's like around
men we we kind of start the same as men
in our in our 20s and we're starting on
out earned men in some major cities but
like the average man makes 45
000 and and Peaks at 55 at 70 000.
that's like average man makes 55 000. no
no he starts no no I make that a week 45
000 in his 20s and then by the time he's
55 that's when his income
um Peaks at 70k but I'm saying 70k I
launched that yearly salary on cockroach
racing
brother we'll put that in a day in a
parlays but we all make our money doing
like technology right and so it's like
what we're gonna [__] on the guy that's
do it let's build the building for us
that's doing the electricity that's
doing the plumbing like we need those
men to do what we do everything is
supply and demand no matter what it is
it like for instance when you go to
Russia there's an abundance of beautiful
women there's literally an abundance of
beautiful women so the value a beautiful
woman out there it's much lower and I
understand that but what I'm arguing is
that those men are doing the hard jobs
but the problem is they're getting paid
less because we're subsidizing women 100
and I don't think women are like putting
in the hours I don't think we're really
like grinding like that I think they're
just stealing money and I can't really
prove this I just think it because
stealing it if the government's giving
it to us it's a small percentage of yeah
I mean there's a small percentage of men
that run these companies that have to
give it to the women and transfer the
wealth to the women somehow well if you
put them all in prison for stealing
there's your 19th Amendment repeal right
there
yeah I think they will have uh some of
them will Factory actually like that a
little bit more grand larceny yeah
put them all behind bars there you go
speaking order is restored
speaking of that
um
we know that four percent I believe
68 of single mothers voted for Joe Biden
okay
this has to be skewed
[__] you does anyone think that election
was real still no of course it was
stolen I mean I think I actually do know
I can almost say this for a fact
I would put my head in a guillotine and
wager this that Trump won if you
actually counted the true votes
absolutely the largest landslide in
world history but I also think he won
California
I think he won calorie that's a stretch
if you don't include the dead people the
[__] immigrants and all the [__]
it might be
um but I will tell you this
um when I look at uh Trump
I I basically went in the White House on
December 15 2020 when I was invited
first numerologist in history to ever be
invited to the White House and I
basically told Trump's advisors set in
the Marines sent them into Pennsylvania
sent to Wisconsin sent them to Georgia
and basically do recounts because you
had to cross the Rubicon at that point
Trump had his position he could have
crossed Rubicon if he did that we would
not have a warrant right now which is
basically a money laundering operation
for your brother and Biden
um when it comes imagine all that money
your body your brother is making and he
tells you what what he said he was broke
he told you he's broke he's broke when
it comes to you but he's making billions
upon billions in funnels I can't even
imagine this could you imagine Barack
Obama who has how many mansions
five Mansions but to you he's broke a
stenius scrooge
Scrooge McDuck yeah he's Christine yeah
that's all he is you know he's all about
himself here's a question does anybody
actually truly believe
that are Republicans actually going to
win an election again because I think
it's just rigged till the end of time
now I I think it's done I I don't
understand what the difference is going
to be in 2024 if they stolen in 2000
that's what I'm saying what is going to
be the difference in 2020 they're just
better prepared now I just don't
understand what the difference is going
to be like Trump you got they stole I
believe you Trump I believe you they
stole the election from you my question
is what is going to be different 2024. I
just don't understand what is all this
oh we're gonna do it this time would you
forget they stole it last time and the
only way Trump can do this is to win by
a landslide that's right I I I
personally believe that Republicans have
to win by landslides now because if it's
two three four five points they'll cheat
they'll find the way if it's 15 20
points that's going to be very very
difficult 100 to cheat so I just don't
see how Republicans gonna pull that off
they didn't even factor in the margin
correctly this last time it was
hilarious they just shut it down for
three days to catch up so how anybody is
still thinking that Republicans are
going to come hard charging blow torches
at the door battering rams and make this
thing happen it's it's a joke this is a
problem we're too nice I don't even know
like
I don't even really know what happened
with the steal in the election I just
know I went to bed and we were winning
and it was my birthday and I thought we
were gonna win and then I woke up and we
lost and I was pissed I was like what it
was my birthday
I made a tweet uh Karma Gary tell her
about her karma what goes around comes
around
um I remember I made a tweet uh before I
I think it was August
2020 that Trump would win and they would
steal the election from him and what do
you know that account was suspended
right after the election shocking
shocking absolutely shocking that they
would suspend my account it wasn't once
wasn't twice 18 freaking times they
suspended my account and by the way
there's a lot of people who like to say
I'm some kind of connected with uh some
kind of Zionist or Rothschilds because
I'm blowing up with numerology and stuff
like that I'm a Jew and Chase shut me
down
I want to make that statement again I am
Jewish and Chase shut me down right
after I went to the White House to visit
president Trump so don't give me this
[__] like Jews don't get it too if
it doesn't none of that [__] matters if
you're a conservative they're coming for
you that's my opinion and I I want to
thank Elon Musk because I believe by him
buying Twitter and making it go this
much more right he is pulled IG he has
pulled Tick Tock a little bit more to
the center that's my opinion because let
me tell you now I can get away with a
lot of stuff now on IG I probably would
have got suspended for two years ago and
the only obvious common denominator is
Elon Musk I agree you guys know the
cycle of strife right cyclist Drive good
good times create weak men weak men okay
I believe gen Z are the strong men
created by the bad times
Generation Z I do because I think 25 of
these guys consider some I get that
sorry let's get that 25 so the other 75
they're gonna be dogs they're gonna be
these are the [__] Rottweilers really
that are gonna get us out of this
they're gonna they're gonna build the
tech it's gonna evacuate People Like Us
who are getting our bank account shut
down because these guys are all [__]
they're all experimental they're [__]
throwing spaghetti at the wall and
seeing what sticks they're the crypto
kids there's the social media kids they
are gonna build the decentralized
banking system 100 gen Z that helps you
and me out maybe there's a Steve Jobs
maybe there's a Steve Wozniak within
Generation Z right now you know right
now they're watching this people
watching and they're gonna build
something and they'll make you look like
you're basically like a million bucks
right now because you're saying what it
is I'm gonna look like Nostradamus but
most of these guys most these guys are
soft as [__] hell a Dana White said
it best he said if your kid is even a
little bit of a Savage he's gonna run
through these [__] beta males like
never before because there's never been
more single mothers than there is right
now 100 they're gonna run through them
so yes the Divide between the Alpha and
the beta is getting whoo
and that's when Society breaks you need
this bottom half to have women yeah you
need the bottom half to have women to
have kids so they can basically keep
Society going the people who don't like
Mass immigration the people who say shut
down the borders
well women have to have kids yeah you
have to you know once women don't have
kids and what I mean by don't have kids
is having abortions every nine you know
months and stuff like that once once
women don't have kids all of a sudden
you have two choices you either let the
Border let the borders open you let the
immigrants in to fill in that vacuum to
buy into the tax system or you do like
Japan you know you're gonna have an
older demographic you just shut down
immigration don't let anyone in and
slowly but surely your Society collapses
so I'm an accelerationist i 100 am all
for this whole gender wildness because I
I truly do believe that all of these fat
feminists with lurid blue hair pierced
nipples doing crazy [__] I think it's a
cry for help I know for a fact this cry
for help and what I think is going to
happen is we're in a correction phase
things are going to get so accelerated
and so out of control that these women
are essentially because they can't say
this verbally right but they can
communicate it in subtext through their
behavior through the [__] you know
what apostamatism is like poisonous
frogs in the rainforest they they're
[__] lured bright colors to show you
their poisonous well that's why these
chicks dye their hair and get all tatted
they're telling you how poisonous they
are right why would they do that because
it's like they're wearing their trauma
right they're embroidering their trauma
on their body it's like a way of like
you know what they're seeking help well
you know resting [__] face they're
basically seeking help 100 it's a cry
for help so my point is in this
accelerator he's going to save them
though well that's my point it's all
gonna Crash and Burn and then what's
gonna spawn out of this is in a new Iron
Guard of men who are going to come in
with an iron fist probably covered in a
velvet glove and they're gonna [__]
smash all of this [__] to a billion
little pieces and it's gonna have to be
rebuilt and then every order is going to
be restored because at this rate you
can't fix this we're too deep in now
this is not a reversible okay I agree we
can only go forward right it's a forward
Escape as the French say cannot go
backwards you gotta skate forward so we
gotta run this [__] into the ground
ride the decline and then that new Iron
Guard of men the most masculine force of
men you have ever [__] seen are about
to be birthed and spawned and they're
going to Blossom and they're going to
annihilate this whole feminist thing and
but it's what the feminists want they
want [__] a strong powerful voice I
agree but the only strong powerful force
I see right now and anyone can correct
me if they think I'm wrong
Muslim men
that that that is the only strong force
I see that's not capitulating and again
I'm not Muslim I'm never gonna play pray
to Allah I'm sorry brother but I'm just
stating fact you can give you two
choices right now you either go to the
BT or you go to the Muslims it's that
simple it's because they they
infiltrated the churches in the 1900s
because they realize they could have
more power and influence the
non-denominational Christian churches
got it the worst but they will allowed
that to happen though who allowed what
well I mean I would say it was a small I
can't remember which family it was I
have to remember the writing but it was
it was basically a small percentage of
like families that had a lot of money
because in the industrial revolution
that was the big that was like when
there was the biggest wealth Gap and so
they realized the best way to influence
the population was through the churches
because people listen to the churches
um so the non-denominational churches
got it the worst but they also started
funding like um that's why we got all
the gay priests from I get it but but
they tried the same stuff with Islam it
didn't work as well
oh I see what you're saying that's what
I'm trying to say they allow that to
happen like for instance if you go to
the uh to Christians in
um Russia Poland Romania you try to talk
[__] about Jesus or all this other stuff
you're probably gonna get your ass
whooped you do that in America they
don't give a damn you can make fun of
Jesus you can do whatever you want here
in America yeah yeah they're not gonna
but in those countries they actually
still care because they haven't been
corrupted and I'm gonna tell you why in
Poland in Russia and all those countries
feminism is very very well
once you have real see the people at who
are low IQ in my opinion they need
something to believe in they need
something to fear I just wonder
um and I'm not going to say this
definitively but I kind of wonder if
it's coming to the Muslims too into
Russia too because like even like the my
employees that work for me that are um
African they're all set like so I always
figured like it was a little better
there but they're like no the young
women are just the same and then I
watched like an interview in Russia of
them interviewing like young women about
feminism and pay equality and it it's
still coming because social media
everyone's unless they've banned social
media all women are so influenced by
social media
um Putin passed the law a couple years
where he repealed
um domestic violence laws so I I I don't
really think that um that you know
feminism maybe maybe what you're talking
about is they're all still in the first
wave of feminism which had some Merit
the first wave first that's a little bit
of Merit no there you don't think you
don't think they had any Merit
whatsoever not really no I I think that
they were one like women didn't even
like them back then if you want listen
if you read the anti like the
anti-suffragettes had more
um supporters than the suffragettes like
they were they were regarded as like
weirdos in the 1800s women didn't even
like these women like there was a
writing I I can't remember the lady's
name but in the 1800s talking about how
they had to like sell this better to
women because women had too good of
lives back then
for them to sell them on feminism that's
why like I don't I don't really no I
don't I don't think it really had Merit
I think women most of history have had
better lives than men I think that um uh
you know listen I'm a numerologist I
believe in that wholeheartedly and even
though I think women as a whole are much
less intelligent than men uh you know
there's the number seven and you know
seven is the number of the genius and
when I look at people women who were
born in the 7 16 25th they're just as
intelligent as men well and again it's a
rare exception like for instance uh
there's not many female bodybuilders in
the world you know so they're they're
stronger than most average men but of
male bodybuilder is always going to be
stronger than no female so there is some
exceptions but they're rare but it's but
it's a misconception that women couldn't
be influential in society the first
female property owner in the United
States was in the 1600s 400 years ago
like women were not oppressed then
they're not oppressed now
um this idea like the first female
millionaire was late 1800s and I think
there's arguably one quicker
um but I don't want to quote get her
money from a divorced husband no well
inherited no I was I think there was a
self-made one quicker but there was a
one of the first feminists that was
funding all this stuff like she divorced
she was like the first Rich divorce it
was in the 1800s
um I wish I could remember all these
names
why should there be an issue of feminism
if you're a woman you're a woman yeah a
man you're a man what's all this
feminism and so forth I don't understand
it I don't get it well I I think that
evil to destroy Society I think that
evil happens when you disrupt the
natural order of the world and it's
weird I'm not like crazy religious but I
guess this is like a religious like
thought but it's like um like I think
the natural order is God men women and I
think it's really interesting how we can
like I don't know almost say our true
feelings about things just in our
language like if you tell a man he's
acting like a woman that's an insult why
would it be an insult because women are
below men but but a woman that acts like
a man almost like can make money and
almost I mean I don't want to say I
think you're gonna get like uh 10 000
marriage proposals right after this
podcast
well and I understand all the good
things well and I'm not even I'm not
even saying like I do it perfectly but
but I think evil happens when you
confuse everyone on the natural order of
the world and I think it's confusing
like give you an example like I spent
the first half of my 20s trying to be a
volleyball player and really I spent you
know my primary reproductive years
chasing after a career that makes zero
dollars and [__] it actually I looked
into it it actually messes up your
hormones and makes you more masculine
that's why you see so many lesbian like
soccer chicks and lesbian basketball
chicks it literally makes you more
masculine and makes you into a man and
so it's like you know I think a lot of
times it all of these institutions I
think women should be athletes
um I I have really I have a hard I don't
know because I really did love it I
really loved playing but I do think
sometimes like things that maybe
as a whole it like if I see what happens
in volleyball and really like it's run
by a lot of feminists and really like
you play until you're 32 and then you
retire you know what I mean like if you
take volleyball today yeah yeah like you
know it's sad because I really do love
the sport but if I look at the outcomes
for a lot of women that play they're not
good and it's like I I think there's
just a lot of Institutions that are
confusing us on the natural order of the
world and trying to make wimp like that
is a masculine thing that's turning a
woman into a man
by the way I sincerely believe all women
will get their best natural physique
just from walking
there isn't nothing inside a gym that
will improve a woman's physique more
than walking
10 000 steps what about running same
thing okay just making sure but the gym
gym culture and women is very bizarre to
me
are most of women who go to the gym
pretty much every day hoes 100 all right
so I mean they're basically looking for
a new hookup every single day if you
spend all your time at the gym and
you're a woman
who's taking care of the children
I I mean that's a good question well and
these children there's some women who
don't want to have babies because they
want to ruin their bodies
and by the way ciao kids destroy women's
bodies I'm not gonna lie about that
um but you know listen that's what you
guys are for
because that's where you guys are for
you're for the wait and the earlier you
have kids I guess it's easier to like
bounce back from it like there's some
hormone or something when you have kids
younger what age what do you think
that's a good idea um well and by the
way it's unfortunate it's unfortunate I
didn't follow it but but I've heard it's
like before the age of 25 if you have
kids like it's easier to come back from
but after like you're I don't I don't
know the science behind it so don't
quote me this is just something I've
heard by the way to answer your question
because I did want to touch on this
about you said why does feminism where
did it come from I truly believe right
dude I think feminism spawned I I think
all the issues with women are truly
men's fault fundamentally talk to me why
I do
is it because men were so weak that they
gave women the right to vote 100 is that
it 100 okay well the deciding vote
on giving women the right to vote did it
because his mom told him so
but the problem is it's a very small
percentage of men making these decisions
for all men he was a Norman Bates type
of fella yeah yeah because his mom was a
suffragette again like the biggest lie
we tell them like the waves of feminism
it's so not true like these women were
not liked like there's a reason we burnt
witches at the stake
there's a reason like witches were
performing abortions that's why they
burnt these [__] witches were
feminists like they literally burnt
these women in villages the fact that
you brought up abortion I want to give
my stance and abortion
um I believe when a woman has a child
it's not that woman's body anymore it is
the child's body just as much as the
woman the difference is the woman's the
bus driver she's the one that decides
what I'm doing what I'm eating what I'm
drinking when I'm sleeping but it's the
baby's body too they're just in the back
seat
so if you're gonna be a woman out here
who says it's my body my choice listen
you best believe in karma you best
[__] believe in karma because I'm
gonna tell you something a lot of women
who basically had abortions
got breast cancer right after
that's why I call Karma
you know it's crazy women have been
killing their kids since the dawn of
time since the dawn of time even in the
1800s like it wasn't uncommon for women
to kill their children I've talked to
some historians that say it was like 10
20 and I think it goes back to back in
like the caveman or like when people
moved in like groups of like 40 I can't
remember what era but they basically if
they had more than two kids they would
slow the whole pack down
so they were just they were just yeah
women killing kids instinctually yeah I
don't know it's just our thing
um to the people listening you know
we've basically told guys you know it's
a it's going to be a tough ride for you
it really is but let me just give you
guys some advice
um the last thing you want to do
is get have a child when you're about 17
18 years old
no matter who you are you're always
going to be in your enemy you're in
astrology it's 17 18. what you want to
do is basically do what I did
have kids under your own sign
if I'm born in the snake year and you
best believe my first child is born in a
snake here because I wanted someone that
I could teach this stuff to if you're
born in a certain you're like a dragon
you should have a dragon child if if you
just apply a little of this knowledge to
your everyday life problems go away I
mean guys I don't have these problems of
women cheating on me I don't have these
problems of women [__] bossing me
around and doing all this other stuff I
don't have any of these problems as a
matter of fact I'm looking at you guys
like you're [__] morons
that's the way I look at all these guys
who start telling me about their women
problems and it doesn't matter if you're
[__] broke or alpha or whatever
if you can't hold down your woman
you fail and I'm gonna tell you guys
something
2016.
was it when I really woke up to the
betaization of males
because you had men out there saying
vote Donald Trump vote Donald Trump they
will go up on podiums vote Donald Trump
and then their wife will cancel out
their vote by voting for Clinton their
daughter will cancel out their vote by
voting Clinton let me tell you bastard
something if you can't convince your own
[__] family members shut the [__] up
because you don't need to convince
anyone else convince your family first
all you men I'm talking to you remember
talking about weak men that's who the
[__] I'm talking to right now don't go
out there on Spaces don't be making
tweets don't be making reels on
Instagram saying vote Trump go talk to
your wife and talk to your daughter and
make sure they don't [__] cancel out
your vote
you know that's what you know my
personality test if I take it it says
I'm very liberal I'm very high in the
trait openness like if a liberal gets a
dog um the dog will be more friendly if
a conservative gets a dog it's going to
protect them like there's certain
personality traits that come with
liberal and conservative and it's funny
because
um in college you know they just are
programming you to be a liberal and
every time I would have like a little
bit of a liberal idea I would come home
and I would I would tell my dad this
like silly idea I learned and he would
just sit down with me and break down
slowly while I was an idiot and that's
how I became a conservative you know
shout out dad because you had a strong
male figure in your life and he turned
you conservative correct yeah because
you because you would have been a
liberal without your dad yes are you
guys listening yeah are you guys
listening you need a strong male figure
no [__] I want to decipher the the
term strong because I think a lot of men
truly don't understand what a strong not
talking about going to gym exactly what
a strong male leadership even looks like
I to me I think it's sort of this
effortlessness like this red pill thing
of all these guys that want to be super
[__] dominant they want to clash
horns lock horns with their girl all day
tell her what to do every second of the
day I think if you awaken the soft power
because look this is the reality okay I
do believe women have more power in
relationships in the sense that they
have the soft power men have hard power
women got the soft power explain what
soft power is soft power means that she
has all the psychological games you know
what I mean like we better eyes
manipulation of course sneakiness and
cunningness that's a that's a that's a
woman's game they can't overpower you
they gotta do they can't overpower you
got to do something but you don't want
to awaken a woman's soft power in a
relationship because women are far more
irrational and they will burn every
[__] thing to the floor
and have a full disregard they will not
give a [__] if you push them far enough
so my question to you was when you say
strong male leadership because to me the
winner in any situation is always just
chilling
that's the definition of a winner winner
is always just cruising not really
working too hard making it look a little
bit effortless the loser is always
chasing the winner
so what is the definition for you of
like a strong man because to me when I
think of a dominant male I don't think
of some [__] who constantly has
to
Clash into his woman all the time I
think that's actually beta so what is
that what do you see as strength sorry
can I one thing because doesn't that
mean you're on the same level if you're
arguing with her on the time like if
like a boss doesn't argue with an
employee he tells her what to do oh she
gets out of line yeah but you're not
going to go back and forth with them for
hours you're like you know what I mean
it's like kind of like if you're going
back and forth that he's arguing with
this chick all the time doesn't that
just make them on the same level there's
got to be some chicks imbalance yeah
otherwise we're just going you're going
to have a whole bunch of savages
yeah we got quite a few of those human
beings they want to do whatever they
want to do you know you have free will
you can do whatever like oh I gave it to
us right yeah you have free will but
there's got to be checks and balances
and that's why there's the law
[Music]
which are more important
God made laws okay yeah so you've got to
have some checks and balances and you
got to know which is the check and which
is the balance God uh the Bible and the
Quran also say put God in front of your
family do you put God in front of your
family yes I don't I never will I do how
can you put a figure that you've never
actually met above your own flesh and
blood it's a belief system okay yeah you
get the people who who are brought up
eating other people what's the question
and that's normal for them do you put
God above your own family yeah
personally I do not I do not either no
you already answered that question I
believe right you put God in front of
you I haven't really I have a really
interesting like view on this and this
is just how I think I think that God is
like in every man and the devil is in
every woman you something that was Pearl
no okay hear me out hear me out who did
the serpent talk to we talked to Eve and
I think that like again the natural
order of the world is God men women
children
and I think the devil uses women to get
to the men
so and I think if women do not submit to
the Natural hierarchy of the world they
get the devil in them and this was kind
of a red pill where I realized that it's
not Daddy Issues it's mostly mommy
issues when you get to the root of it
most like people like Kanye in front of
our eyes right he thought he had daddy
issues but he really had mommy issues
that's a really common theme and I think
a lot of times the devil like uses women
to abuse the men and get to the men and
I think guys when left to their own
devices really are they're benevolent
their benevolent think about it they
didn't have to let us vote they did not
have to let let us do anything they
could be graping us everything they were
manipulating no but wait but wait but
the thing is if men get too out of line
they just kill each other like if you go
around raping all these [__] then
someone's some other guy's gonna kill
you look at the Aztec empire right the
Aztec Empire was doing all the human
sacrifice and crazy
um Cortez came over with a with 400 men
got all the Drives together to [__] him
up and took them all down have you ever
heard the term
um
no I don't know the translation from
Russian is eight to eighty
ever hear of that term no it was very
common in World War II after the
Russians invaded Berlin they said eight
years old to 80 year old grandmothers
they did not care see that's what
happens when men lose Wars when your men
are weak women start getting raped
because that's exactly what happened
when uh the Nazis lost and Germany was
being taken over by Russian troops they
did not care they raped anything that
walked on two feet women were
specifically cutting themselves with
knives so they would look ugly so they
would not get raped this is what the
reality of the situation when women have
weak men around well and what I'm not
saying I'm not saying that men don't do
terrible things or like men don't become
evil at times but usually those men were
raised Again by women and so I think
they get the spirit of the devil from
the women
and and usually if they get too evil
another group of men will come and take
them out usually I like I like this take
because I think women are adept
women in a relationship with a man they
are
they are like hounds they they will
sniff out weakness a woman will break
any man's system okay that's what I I
believe women are system Breakers
they're natural system Breakers if
you're a man running a system on a woman
running game running red pill uh being
toxic on purpose trying to be
unavailable withdraw attention all that
[__] give it enough period of time
and you will 100 crack under a woman's
[__] test because women I do believe in
a relationship and this is kind of going
in line with the this isn't lockstep
with the evil component
I don't see it as evil because I see it
as nature
and I honor nature above anything else
but I do think women are designed to
constantly try to break and whittle a
man down to nothing and if he can
withstand those tests constantly
he gets all the spoils and the riches
um I I would tend to agree with you
um I think that because if you sometimes
a man has everything going for him he's
the top of the world everyone loves him
he's famous as hell has all the money in
the world and but when he gets back home
blah blah blah blah blah always arguing
or always and and here's the thing I I
want men to understand this you can't
please a woman
you don't try to please women it doesn't
matter what you give them over time it's
never going to be enough exactly it's
just the reality of the situation this
is why I was saying you cannot fake
being an alpha because a woman will
break your system it's gonna happen at
some point long enough time scale woman
will break out your system and snuff it
out they are the Masters at it so none
of this [__] can be faked and to your
point
it can be fake for a little bit though
100 but here's the here's the thing if
you trick a woman
into loving you are liking you through
game or somebody you're not right a
Persona let's say the Persona wins the
woman when she tells you she loves you
you don't believe her
can't believe her because you know if
she knew the truth exactly so these guys
end up self-sabotaging
before they get discovered because they
have that what do you call it imposter
syndrome
so that that's why these guys abandon
the relationship because they're like
those self-destruct guys will come to me
all the time they're like brute I'm in
love with this chick why can't I stop
destroying the relationship
I'm like ah it's one of those game guys
he tricked her and he does he doesn't
believe that it's built on a solid
foundation so he's got a bounce before
she's inevitably gonna find out that he
was full of [__] anyway okay that's a
common okay that's a common thing let's
move the subject to a piece of garbage
like adam22 uh when when this guy
actually pimps out his own wife
at what level do we say yo I'm all for
chasing clout as everyone in this room
is but there's levels you don't go
there's lines you don't cross I mean in
all honesty what's this guy gonna do
start pimping out his daughter when
she's of age I mean this is absolutely
disgusting
how do we stop people in society from
doing things like this because what
happens is I don't give a [__] about
Adam 22 but he influences a lot of
people and now people are gonna be like
yo
if this guy's doing it why can't I do it
and you know what the most interesting
thing about it is every time I talk to a
people
about open relationships it was always
the woman
it was always the woman that said yo
let's try this and at Adam 22 situation
it was the woman who actually did it
she's like yo let's do this I had a
podcast with a a whole bunch of females
and she one of them was in an open
relationship and I asked her flat out
whose idea was it mine
it's always the women who wants to push
the envelope sexually
if she's not being pleased properly yeah
well and all the most family
dysfunctions in my opinion start from
the women it's either a guy that was
raised by a woman I'm gonna have to get
you armed security after this bro I'm
telling you I'm telling you and even
like the oh God this is a hot take a lot
of the alcoholic drug addicted men were
driven that way because a woman drove
them crazy
and that's a lot of them so you're
telling me you believe a lot of men
started using alcohol and drugs because
the woman drove into it I agree with
that because alcohol I mean a lot of
these drugs that they're so there's
actually Carl Jung said that men drink
to become women and women drink to
become men
I believe that's interesting to believe
that's very interesting yeah and I'm not
saying all like some people were just
you know I have a cousin that was a
crackhead he was just a crackhead but he
was raised by a domineering mother
so you know a lot of times like when you
when you see like a dysfunction in the
family and you can you can tell like
okay before Will Smith and Jada it came
out that like they were all like [__]
up you know before that all that came
out remember they were like the perfect
couple everyone loved Will and Jada
Smith I knew they were [__] up because
I looked at the kids and I was like
normal kids raised by normal parents
shouldn't be like that because I was
like there's no way in hell I'd be doing
whatever whatever the [__] the open
relationship [__] I'm like something's
off and it's usually the mother's
dysfunction because again I really think
men naturally have gotten them like men
naturally want to do the right thing
even when you guys kill you kill for a
reason now sometimes it's a stupid
reason but usually it's like respect
like people used to die all the time
because of like disrespect you know like
they'll and honor like their brother you
know if someone [__] with your boy
you're going and fight and like women
we're conniving like look at the
difference between frat houses and
sorority house
sorority house is like I I can still
tell you the [__] I hated in high
school this was 10 years ago men men on
the other hand like we we hold on to
things we don't let things go it's just
like what it is men will go back to
their frat houses and love everyone like
they'll come back they might get too
drunk or maybe get into a stupid fight
but like it's like the dynamic is a lot
more family-like than a sorority house
that's one thing I've noticed about
women like for instance if men hate each
other they can still respect each other
as a man if I don't like you I can still
respect your accomplishments oh God if a
woman [__] hates you she's gonna hate
the way you walk the way you talk the
way you say things the way you work
she's gonna hate everything about you
that is one of the biggest differences
between men and women that I've seen men
can actually deal and actually respect
people they don't like women oh you know
you know what else I've noticed guys
they'll like fight and then like it's
weird they'll like get into a fight and
then after they're like cool yeah
all the time because you respect the guy
yeah where it's like if two girls gonna
do a fist fight they're never gonna talk
again
or even like just a verbal fight you
know what I'm like never again we're
made differently yeah we may differ this
way you can't have a man try to be a
woman
and be a woman no they're trying you
know no but your her point was
fascinating because she's saying that
women started the Cascade of abuse in
men and men getting [__] up right so I
agree they're turning to these compounds
these drugs like alcohol et cetera those
are those are there's a feminine Spirit
infused in there so they get abused by
the mom and then they turn to the drugs
to get abused again and replay the
trauma and that's another thing women
are more likely they're the most likely
person to abuse the kid I think I think
maybe stepfather's up there too but like
the moms the milk was most likely one to
kill the infant I'll push back after
after the when women obviously kill with
abortion but after the child is born
um first year infants listen I've heard
a lot of stories about men molesting
kids not too many of women actually
doing this the last thing it's usually
it's more likely the stepdad which is
which is typically what I'm a woman's no
but it's the woman's Choice oh okay so I
see what you're saying so the woman
allowed that evil to come in the house
yeah yes by being promiscuous and stuff
like that right right so no this I I
said the woman is the most likely I
didn't say sexually abused I said abuse
so the woman is the most likely one to
abuse
um and step dad's up there too
but yeah
I think the problem is uh women
you know when you're having sex with a
man on top of the woman
yeah I think they have a thing about
that you know every time I get in the
pigment one of my life's I tell them I
didn't create myself to be a man I
didn't create you to be a woman but
that's how the Creator made it so he
just deal with it and you lie in your
back and I'll take care of business
right I know I feel it I don't think
that I think they have a thing with you
know being you know the weakest I mean
you being on top of them unless it's
your brother they don't like that unless
it's your brother I I listen I got I I
got every single penny I own on this
planet that Michelle would whoop Rock's
ass
yes he probably don't pull in the
strings back up the Brinks truck I'm
going in on that BET right now and we're
talking about one of the biggest power
layers of the world right now literally
red Michelle Obama's minus 800 it just
the line just opened 800 8 000 brother
what the [__] the line just opened in
Reno it's moving up every couple seconds
[__] second you know um speaking of
gambling brother
um listen I gamble sometimes between
like 10 20K a day I do parlays you know
people look at me like I'm like one of
the biggest gamblers they know brother
I'm doing peanuts compared to what the
[__] you're doing you show me parlays
that you put like a hundred thousand two
hundred three hundred thousand and hit
like for four or five million I've
actually seen those with my own eyes how
brother
if I lose 10 20 000 I'll go to sleep
like a baby that shit's not gonna but if
I lose like half a mil oh boy I'm I'm
not gonna sleep too well how the [__] do
you put that much money down and still
sleep at night I mean listen and you're
talking to somebody who does this too
dude if I lose I sleep even better at
night explain that because I know I'm
going on the war path tomorrow
[Laughter]
how long you've been gambling brother
forever since I was like 17. 17 yeah in
my profession for almost 20 years
tell us about tell us not about your
biggest win and your biggest loss they
just win I want 11 million in 24 hours
11 million doing one on went on an
absolute despicable heroic statistics
possibility Terror yeah just Parliament
two three four teamers absolute the
aggression meter was through the roof
the book was act it was literally
terrified my host actually called me and
he said the back office called us they
said they have never seen aggression
from a player like this in the history
of the book they said when you bet with
us it's not even like you're trying to
take our money it's like you're betting
against the world
they were like who the [__] are you like
what what kind of animosity drives you
to bet these numbers with us I
um my best run was I made I I mean
obviously nothing compared to your
numbers I made about 1.2 million in
about three weeks in Atlantic City
they kicked me out of resorts oh yeah
they literally kicked me out like you
know if you go uh spend money in the
hotel you know you spend the type of
money I'm spending they usually give you
a room and you know I'm and there for a
while I just call up yo give me an
extension one day I call up you're like
oh yeah you gotta go I'm like what do
you mean I got it they're like you gotta
go that was that legal yeah they don't
like winners they unperson you like
Stalin just get unpersoned erased from
photographs this it's unreal I beat him
so bad because they used to let you uh
move the over under lines could you
imagine that Line's at eight and a half
you can move it down to six and a half
and I just murdered them they changed
the whole system because of me
of course
here's the thing with my style my style
is so dangerous because I can go the
opposite way just as quickly you know
what I mean like I can make 11 mil but I
could torture I got 11 mil same day and
and I will be unfazed because I'm
trained now I've been doing this for
such a long time I I'm very very very
cold-blooded towards it how many times
have you lost a million in a day thank
you
probably more than there are [__]
bacteria in this room okay so you do
understand that most people
will never see a million dollars most
people will never see the kind of money
that I want in a 24-hour period
so that's my point is like the way that
I'm living and I'm like shedding lives
I'm literally shedding I'm living the
last year I feel like I've lived 100
years
I'm writing a book about it right now
I'm literally chronicling the experience
that I had the last year the wisdom that
I have learned from the hardcore risks I
have taken dude we're not even just
talking money like it gets to the point
when you're putting up five million
dollar bets you're that's a blood stake
bone investment what do you do when you
put five million dollar bets are you
looking at your phone are you looking at
the TV smoking squares 24 7. what are
you doing because that's got to be a lot
of stress brother Gatling gunning
cigarettes any chance sometimes I have
too lit in each hand
i'm Gatling gunning them and for sure
yeah I'm pacing but I try I like sports
betting because I can live a normal life
I don't have to sit in a dungeon in a
[__] poker table for 10 hours a day
you don't like to grind that [__] oh
[__] no place a sports bet go take a nap
go walk with my girl
try to have a nice day but yes of course
it's stressful it's when you have a bad
day like for instance
um if I lost like 20 30k my wife can't
tell I'll be Stone Cold you won't be
able to tell anything oh my girl can
tell so if you lose like a mill you show
it right uh door hinges are being ripped
off oh okay okay okay I got you I got
you but then they're being replaced with
better ones with better ones I got you
um
is gambling Haram or is losing Haram
because I gotta tell you as a gambler
I've had ups and downs I've had months
where I lost 100K I have months that
I've won three fourth out three 400k
I've had that I'm a winner that man
right there is a winner we've made money
gambling
how why is that Haram
explain that because it's in the Quran
well I got I understand that but is you
know is there a little bit deeper than
just it's in the Quran
I'm not trying to understand and you
just follow God's law and that's it he's
got the wisdom he knows he's the one but
don't you don't you believe as a logical
man that if you're actually good at
something and you know you make money at
it how can it be bad if it's not hurting
anybody
I don't have an answer for that I just I
just think losing is Haram losing's
wrong but we're all speculators to some
degree right of course you know like for
instance when you when they talk about
religion and they talk about speculation
is bad and you know uh astrology and
numerology are bad I mean Black Rock and
Vanguard these are financial
institutions that have like nine eight
trillion dollars they have a software
program called Aladdin and this thing
speculates that's that's what it does
and they make money on this speculation
and a lot of Saudi royal families
Muslims are in there so why is it
gambling is Haram when it comes to
sports but not the stock market I always
I always found that very interesting
that they would say oh if you put money
on the Knicks oh that's bad but if you
gamble on the stock market or gamble in
the housing market oh that's kosher
which is arguably more rigged by the way
100 by the Federal Reserve oh the fact
that you can make 15 million and then
lose 15 million you know like it cancels
out everything
so you know what's the point well I mean
you know at the end of the day as long
as you're up a couple shackles more than
you lost
[Music]
just not for you huh brother no I don't
gamble you know Pearl you ever Gamble
um okay like not really
um I think I've done it like three times
in my life maybe four guys
um listen you can be
um
one of those people who are very close
with your woman you can be one of those
people who talk to your woman about
everything don't don't don't tell your
woman about gambling stuff they don't
want to hear that [__] man you talk
about masculizing a woman giving your
stress yeah that's gonna have a woman
start gambling [__] parlays you're
gonna see how masculine she gets real
quick
the way I look at it is that I don't
have to gamble to be with you
there you go brother I didn't have to
lose 15 million to be with you there you
go brother uh by the way I'm his agent
now
yeah anyways um let's switch gears
because we have a lot to talk about and
I think we have about another hour to do
it
um
this economy
to me
is pretty much you either can make money
through the computer you can't
either doing a nine-to-five job you're
going to college you're doing that
racket or you can be a cons or a content
creator
and try to make it that way but I'm
going to be honest it's just like
anything else I mean how many people
want to be like Pearl there's only one
how many people want to be like you
there's only one I pretty much handcap I
handicap my industry I own my place I
own my [__] field no one listening to
this even knows the name of another
numerologist
that's that's the that's a that's a fact
but you know not everyone's going to be
able to make it with computers and I'm
getting really worried about AI
I really believe that what you talked
about that little wrecking point is
coming real close because sooner or
later these AIS are going to put
everyone on the business
truck drivers you know how do you have a
capitalistic Society if the very bottom
doesn't have income I mean that's the
reason slavery was ended slavery was end
it wasn't ended in 1860s because the
white man picked up a conscience slavery
was ended because they needed capitalism
how do you have capitalism
and slavery you don't have it because a
lot of people don't understand this but
during those times in the South 95 95 of
white folks during slavery were poor as
hell too how are you gonna have a a job
that pays a living wage when you have
slave labor to compete with that's why
they stopped slavery because you they
couldn't have a capitalistic Society
with slave that's why it stopped
you need a viable middle class for
capitalism to work so I wonder if we're
going to start
um getting things like handmade again do
you know what I mean because it's like
the quality of even like the quality of
like tables like like everything that we
have has gone down this just that's
because of free trade that's because of
free trade see what happens is
um
back in the day uh say for instance the
American workers were at a steel plant
and it cost them 10 000 uh dollars to
make a certain piece of equipment right
well all of a sudden the people in China
the people in Vietnam are actually doing
the same stuff for three four thousand
so all of a sudden all these people like
well wait a second let's fire these
Americans and start Outsourcing
everything that has a trickle-down
effect sooner or later the people at the
middle start losing their jobs and all
of a sudden the economy starts becoming
like this yeah I don't know I was just
wondering if maybe I was I had a couple
theories I was like well maybe a lot of
women's jobs will be eliminated and then
we'll be back
the oldest profession in the world is
not going to get eliminated oh what are
you talking about that cam work the AI
chicks the sex bots they're coming yeah
but I refuse to believe that um that's
very unusual by the way what's that
anybody who is going to indulge in the
AI girlfriend is gay because those are
built by men
are building products that are fondling
you that is
brother there's uh men out there who
have girls who are getting run into four
or five times a week and then they're
going down on them so you want to talk
about actual Behavior bro that's right
there you're essentially let's talk
about Logan Paul his girlfriend has been
around or the wife that's going to take
his bag in a couple years he's been
around with Leonardo DiCaprio a whole
bunch of other guys oh my gosh you know
what I'm talking about Leonardo DiCaprio
is like the kiss of death on these
relationships because I I realized once
they're 25 they're out no like no no no
I'm saying like he curses these women's
relationships because Giselle dated him
too
I was like I was like I hope Blake
Lively makes it because that's another X
that graduate like graduated but dude
the the AI [__] is just Revenge of the
Nerds right it's the Nerds have been
[__] on by women their whole life so now
they have the opportunity to kind of get
their clap back their comeuppance well I
think Jeff Bezos uh was coming up like a
nerd but you know average since he got
his big bag
um you know he doesn't look too much
like a nerd anymore uh the the problem
with Jeff Bezos is you know he basically
got a big bag and he dumped his woman
and
I I don't know what to tell women and
men except to learn numerology and
astrology learn who you're compatible
with learn who you're not compatible
with it's going to save you so much
trouble in life I mean you spoke about
Charlie Sheen Charlie Sheen's born in uh
1965 the year of the snake and he
married Denise Richards born in 1971
year of the pig pig and snake are enemy
signs
what about the kids that they brought
into the world
they're gonna have a [__] up life
because these people didn't take the
time to understand how numerology
astrology works I mean listen if I was
married four or five times you guys can
invalidate everything I said but the
fact of the matter is I've been at this
for two decades two decades
no issues people will need to turn back
not to God in my opinion I understand
what you're saying Malik or all this
other stuff start turning back to
knowledge start turning back to what
actually works again I tell people all
the time millionaires might not use
numerology astrology
how do you manually manage it so that
you get kids
who were born in the right time
no you basically have to time it out how
do you time it well for instance um I
wanted a kid born in a snake year
because and that was 2013. that's when
my kid was born but I was married in
2004. I waited eight years I planned
this out and by the way guys my woman
don't take birth control pills
you guys you red pill [__]
[__] complain about women all the
time they're emotional they're crazy and
then your [__] stuffing pills down
their [__] throat because you can't
pull out
that's beta as [__] to me that's beta as
[__] to me have some [__] pull out
game [__] that's what you guys
need to do so uh going back to what the
hell you were saying I care nine months
oh you can't well that's why you got
howdy no my thing is this is that you
know we're made to be
we're made to be be what just be you
know we're not supposed to be pulling
out doing that you're supposed to have
sex and reproduce yeah but so what I'm
saying is this is
I couldn't afford kids in 2004 2005
2006. and the last thing I'm gonna do is
bring a child in this world in poverty I
wasn't gonna do that I was broke in 2006
2007 2008 I was not bringing a child in
this world while I was broke the thing
is poor people tend to have more kids
it's like a whole psyop this like you
need a certain amount of money to have
children uh my friend like we kind of
broke down we did an episode on this on
my show I don't know how broke you were
so maybe that was it but I I I do think
there's a lot of propaganda telling
people they can't afford kids
um when if you homeschool the kids if
you you really just need like low food
costs low clothes costs and then you can
hand them down like like my friends a
stay-at-home mom that kind of like broke
this down uh I had a felony I hit a cop
in 1998 I couldn't get a job yeah so so
it was very it would have been very very
difficult you know um by the way this is
before numerology so I try to hear how
could you see this coffee okay this is
way before numerology right so no I'm
not saying for you but I kind of
understand like the religious point of
view behind it because you're kind of
playing God when you're like you know
like pulling out like birth control like
I mean well if you're pulling out how
are you playing God
um because like because again you're
you're supposed to be you're not
supposed to what what do you mean you're
not supposed to well hold up hold up
hold on what purpose of having sex yeah
like
what's the point you're gonna have 20 30
kids I can't afford 20 30 kids
well what people used to do it like my
uh my 20 30. well my I'll give you an
example so my my dad is the son of a
fireman and on a fireman's salary they
had 13. 13. and so like yeah feminism
really like this is all part of feminism
it's like to have to get married in your
later to late 20s and have two kids like
two kids is feminism okay I'm gonna I'm
gonna make this abundantly queer if I
had to have
20 to 30 kids hang me right now okay you
can hang me right now because I ain't
dealing with that stuff that's too much
for me other people might be able to do
it other people you know yeah that's
fine but I'm not doing it right but my
point more is that like a hundred years
ago the average was five and before that
it was even more so it's like and we
have a higher standard of living now
than we did a hundred years because we
have less kids
well yeah partially but but like the
thing is like people used to kind of
make it work like people used to do
hand-me-downs they used to do like you
eliminate a lot of costs by not buying
new clothes but like my friend got
chickens right okay you know there's
there's ways around this there's there's
ways to do it but is that the type of
life you want to live well I mean that's
that
quality of life matters right well I
mean not always like a lot of quality
life doesn't matter not not always that
you because it's not about you is the
point it's about the family it's about
reproducing as much as possible like you
know in certain cultures right how many
kids do you want
um I mean I always said when I get
married it's just as men like I've never
wanted to like plan it like I've just
wanted once I'm married see what happens
um I I think you know I've always
thought four I think maybe I probably
would four yeah you know but I think I
might be able to get started I know that
was a problem I was like I think I
waited too long unfortunately but
um you know we'll see hopefully you know
before I mean
um I'm I'm cool with two yeah I'm cool
I'm packing up shops I'm done and by the
way the highlight of my day
when I'm home
and when I wake up and the kid comes in
the morning gives me a hug and says
Daddy I love you that is the highlight
of my day everything after that is
downhill well I'll I'll tell you one
thing too it's also
um leading to a lower IQ population
because richer people have less kids
to the population but but just because
they're richer doesn't necessarily mean
they have higher IQs yeah but it
correlates like that's the number one
indicator of lifelong success is IQ
number two is I know I know plenty of
smart people were broken no I'm I'm I
understand there's exceptions but we're
talking about General Trends right and
people that are smarter tend to make
more money in general I I know so
there's a lot of women right now who are
making a lot more money than men which
you said before so what that basically
says is no not the smarter people tell
you well I'll tell you one thing about
women is that is that is another problem
is that women make more money and then
we don't reproduce so a lot of hierarchy
I would say a lot of higher IQ women
don't reproduce yes that would probably
be a big problem because they've been
brainwashed by feminism right but what's
it 90 now a college educated women
initiate divorces
um not that they admit when they do
divorce they do initiate it yes yes of
course but you got to be smart to make
money
um I I would say I I don't think I don't
think if you're I don't think if you're
if you're a woman and you got a big rack
and you got a nice ass all you got to do
is put that [__] on the only fans you're
gonna make money there's nothing about
smart the smart guys are the ones who
invented the computer invented the
interview those who are all men and the
women are taking advantage of that yeah
I'll give you an example like in
Corporate America you see these like
women rocking around like they own the
place they're not really that smart when
you talk to them they're kind of dummies
you know what I mean especially you were
just in the DC area there's a lot of
stupid women making a lot of money out
there but it's just because these
corporations are are so there's some
truth to what he's saying like these
corporations do reward women for
basically like doing nothing because
they have diversity hires you know so
it's kind of it does skew it a little
bit but you know it just kind of depends
on the industry
but yeah there is some I met this one
chick and she told me to go into Tech
this is a couple years ago and I
couldn't figure out how this girl this
was this stupid was making so much money
she was like she made like a hundred and
ten thousand and this was like five
years ago so it was less inflated and I
was like how the hell is this [__]
making so much money it didn't click
until five years later when they fired
everyone at Twitter what happened when
the rubber met the road at Twitter right
and they needed to make money because
they're losing money they fired all the
women all these you know white ladies in
HR telling all the men
[Music]
I've never had a woman boss no they're
not great yeah I don't I don't think I
ever will in all honesty yeah and even
even the way I've structured like my
company like I then I do have a wife
well let me rephrase that I do have a
wife so I do have a little bit of this
so let me rephrase that a little bit
even even the like everything I've been
starting like at my you know men are in
management in general you know I'm not
saying there could never be a woman
that's the exception but I knew like as
a woman I can't handle stress the same
way men handle stress nor do I think you
should no I I don't want to and so it's
like nice if [__] hits the fan to just
be like all right tell me what I'm
supposed to do
you know
um I think naturally that you know you
got smart women and smart and
intelligence I think not ascribed
to
your gender
but your gender well women are much less
intelligent than men as a whole their
brains are 15 smaller they're much more
emotionally based men are much more
logically based now are you going to
tell me there's not a woman out there
who's very logical of course there are
I've met them but it's it's very rare
you know it's like finding a verb it's
like finding a version of foreign
because physically a man is stronger
than a woman
and so the man the woman has got to be
submissive
she should be submissive what about your
brother that doesn't seem to be the case
with him meaning well I mean it looks
like Michelle Obama's running the show
that's his thing you know
you know was he always was he always a
weak man
well he was to me he was always a
feminate you know like he was always
like soft and
nice guy who was a nice guy was he
raised by a single mother yeah he had no
strong father figures no is that why
he's a Democrat
sure that's hard to say yeah but
Democrats I like that they're kind of
soft people they're into anything and
everything you know
and uh they they believe in everything
they believe in everything you know
anything goes
but I don't believe that that's the way
it's supposed to be because there's some
things that are meant for some people
like
can't have a woman you know lifting
weights I mean she lift weights yeah but
just
there's a level at which she can't go
any further you know and when they start
taking steroids you know so there's some
things that are meant for every each and
every one of us naturally you know
but right now people are trying to make
things manufactured and they're fitting
it to be what they want it to be as
opposed to what it's supposed to be and
that's what's messing up everything and
every everything in the world right now
because we don't know
the parameters we don't know the limits
because you can't have even your rights
like my rights here they will only go as
far as my arm goes because when you
stretch it out then there's going to be
a Clash I got to give you some space
when I'm doing like this
so we got to know where parameters are
and the only way to know that is when
you're brought up
well properly
the right kind of values or you have
people puppeteering you when I when I
look at your brother he's born in 1961
the year of the ox when you come to
power
2009 the year of the ox so it's always
there it's always there what you know I
look at your brother uh he was 47 years
old when he became president United
States four and seven eleven he's born
eight four nineteen sixty one eight four
one nine six one adds up to 29 2 9 11.
when I always look at certain things
that people on power always have it
I always tell people there's basically
three numbers when it comes to this game
the top guys top women usually have
three numbers number one 11.
but do you think that he's the power
behind all this so this no no I think I
think I think Valerie people I don't
think there's a few people out there
or or a council Valerie Jarrett is
basically his Handler have you ever met
marriage art no okay well he he kept her
far away from you uh Valerie Jarrett is
a Barack Obama's Handler I believe she
gets uh her orders from the Rothschilds
okay I believe that I cannot prove that
but that's what I believe
um when I saw that your brother
is the first president in U.S history
who left the White House but didn't
leave Washington DC I'm like oh I wonder
why barack's staying in DC after Trump
went in office because every other
president went on you know to on
vacations he's got four mansions he can
go all over the place he stayed why
because he was running the Deep State he
was the one who was running the whole
operation he kneecapped Trump's
presidency with fake Russian
investigations fake investigations all
sorts of [__] but broke yes broke
man right
he's full of [__]
do you do you have any respect left from
your brother no I don't
once you lose it what was the final draw
uh I lost it when he when he left office
216 or eight years you know I've been
supporting him
you know how many times you've been in
the White House many times and you were
there supporting him through thick and
thin through thick and thin and then he
left the White House what happened got
nothing back you know he just left his
leg
there was nothing why couldn't he give
you a job
I mean you are his brothers I mean my
brother works for me he said I wasn't a
citizen what's that matter I don't know
because you have a green card don't you
since 1980 yeah you ever you've been in
this country since 85 1985. okay so and
I was working
you know and he tells me that I don't
I'm not a citizen I said to myself
that's the first time when I got a you
know that alarm went off and I said this
guy something wrong with it Pearl could
you imagine that your brother or sister
was the president United States and they
wouldn't even
try to give you a job I mean would that
bother you it's not really that I wanted
a job I just wanted to be of assistance
you know to be by his side
you know to help him out
I said look I'm a Muslim I might help
you with these these Muslims over there
you know JFK and RFK they were together
they were helping each other I mean
sometimes sometimes brothers are
together like the tape Brothers I don't
like the Tates but you got to respect
the bond that Tristan and Andrew have
together then you have other pieces of
[__] like Logan and Jake Paul uh listen
um I I think Logan is the biggest piece
of [__] [__] on this planet
I kind of like Jake
I think you know I I look at Jake he
seems like a stand-up individual he's
fighting for UFC fighters to get better
health contracts and pay he's actually
done more for the sport of boxing uh
than anyone else since Floyd Mayweather
so he's done it but I look at Logan and
I'm like wow what a selfish individual
he basically went on a podcast and said
I'm a better boxer than you even though
he got his ass whooped twice and Jake's
out here knocking people out like what
the hell
yeah I didn't see the fight I don't know
you're not a Jake Paul fan are you no I
don't really care I'm like I got you I
don't know I watch it do you know who
Jake Paul is no do you know who Andrew
Tate is no
I know
this is a man from Kenya he never heard
you uh do they know who Gary the numbers
guy is in Kenya they do oh there you go
[__]
you know um
when I look at everything that's going
around uh in society today it's honestly
what Pearl says you can say it a hundred
times it's feminism it's we need to
repeal 19 uh and by the way I think that
shirt's gonna sell like hotcakes her
peel 19. you're gonna let's make that
[__] mainstream bro yeah
just like they said make America great
again in 216. repeal 19 in 2004. are you
with the Malik I'm with you yes
and and honestly it's for our own good
because it's not it's messing with the
natural order of the world they're
telling us we can make decisions like
men we're not meant to make decisions
like men we're not meant to live life
like men do and when we do it leads to
our own unhappiness
so I I think it's just back to like
women or dummies let's get it that's it
have you have you met have you met any
intelligent women in your opinion oh
yeah I just say as a group we're kind of
dummies but even what percentage but
even intelligent women I will say are
still stupid when it comes to mate
selection I would say like most women at
some point have made dumb decisions when
it comes to like mate selection even
smarter why why do you think they do
that is it because of lust is it because
of peer pressure why I think women would
rather be there's a couple things like I
think in the old days right you would
watch MTV like a music awards whatever
it was and you realize that was not real
right
now we have women that have access to
these celebrities right and these
Entertainer and it's so crazy when I ask
girls on the show about their exes how
many's or Like Rappers entertainers
whatever it is and so it's like we have
access to these men and we think it's
real life but it's not and we have
access it's like the women would rather
be the king's concubine than the
peasant's wife but now we have access to
all the kings that's never happened what
percentage of women do you think would
rather be the king's concubine
I think most women would rather be the
king's concubine
um maybe like
I think 100 of women no yeah I disagree
with that I think there's no way it
can't be 100
um I mean but remember like what is the
King right women value different things
so what are the top three things in your
opinion of women value money was one of
them
um probably piping them down good is
another one what's the third
nowadays like a strong masculine
leadership is so rare God that's so rare
you do actually want a man telling you
what to do
okay
um what if you think that he's making a
bad decision do you speak up or do you
be submissive
um well I'm gonna be like you know being
who I am it's am I am I going to
struggle with that yeah probably but I
think at the end of the day I've learned
it's like really nice to just know it's
on him and not me
that's just like what I uh uh I
understand yeah so it's like okay if I
don't agree I might give you my take but
it's like at the end of the day it's
it's nice to know that like I don't have
to stress out about the outcome of the
decision it's on him it's not me I see
um you don't want pressure on you
no I don't handle pressure super well do
you think women handle pressure well no
no and even that's why I say even me
like I'm not I'm not saying I'm gonna do
this perfectly right and that's why I
think people get irritated because
they're like Pearl why aren't you just
like create like super feminine woman
I'm not saying I'm probably gonna
struggle with it too but it's like if we
can't agree at least you know what the
right thing is yeah and that's what I'm
saying if we can't agree on what the
ideal is then how do we improve as women
we can't like right now we can't even
have a conversation as women to say hey
the ideal is to not nag your husband the
ideal is to trust him this is what we
are strong the ideal is to stay in shape
not get fat like this is what we're
striving for but it's like I can't even
have a conversation like a conversation
with women and say hey guys we should
listen to our husbands without them
saying well but are you gonna do it
probably not perfectly probably not but
you know all we can really do is do the
best we can and try to improve there's
some women out there who won't stop
they'll keep talking they won't shut up
do you think in the 18 and by the way
this is going to be controversial do you
think in the 1800s
um women were more subservient because
they knew if they got out of the line
they might face physical punishment do
you think that in itself might have
um kept them in check maybe a little bit
but there was also um they had like a
Contraption they had like a chastity
belt no no they had a Contraption to
like put over women's like mouths if
they nag too much what was that called I
I can't remember I tweeted it though
there was like a picture like literally
and yeah I'm learning stuff to do today
like husbands could have prosecuted
their wives for nagging too much I mean
men are naturally benevolent men like
naturally they don't want to really you
can prosecute your wife for what nagging
yeah nagging
oh
yeah but women also could prosecute her
husband for not paying all the bills it
went both ways yeah yeah yeah it worked
both ways and uh not like Islam yeah
yeah
I know and and so but a lot of times we
look at these institutions and say they
were so crazy instead of like asking why
they were the way they were I think
that's like the worst mistake in history
is looking at it through the lens of
today instead of the lens of the time
and and the truth of the matter is us
women like we just hold on to things I
don't know what like I'm not even saying
I don't do it but it's like for some
reason women love bring it back I know I
know we do we're like I love those of
what happened yesterday a woman will do
something wrong I know and then she'll
bring up well you did that five years
ago you did that 10 years ago and this
is what I realized If We Hold On To too
much I see women go crazy in their 40s
like 40s to 50s because it's like 20
years no it's like um I think it's like
the demons taking over them I have weird
views on it but like because like think
about the anger that builds up if you're
really you have to forget like in life
you just have to forget the mean things
that people have done to you because
otherwise you're just gonna be angry
especially women at least and you don't
believe in Revenge
um not in a marriage I don't okay I
think yeah what your end like I think
men are meant to fight women aren't and
I and I think like at all man well yeah
like but I think like women we're
supposed to be like selfless like that's
what we're our goal anyway because we
cannot hold on to anger we cannot
remember like trauma traumatic things
like men can and so I just noticed when
women have spent 20 years thinking about
every single thing their husband has
done wrong the husband becomes a shell
of a guy or he's not like the king of
his own house and the woman just becomes
crazy because she hasn't any anyone to
check her for 20 years and tell her that
she's insane and we're all insane Malik
is a man who's had uh many wives we
won't name the number but you've had
many wives as it's allowed in Africa and
Islam
um have you noticed what she's saying is
true no she's telling the truth it's
just the way it's supposed to be and
that's an it's natural like that because
things
Iran is the dominant he's supposed to
have expressed his dominance not even
that his natural supposed to be like
that and like I was saying that
sometimes the problem is
with women you know they sometimes they
don't accept that
and then when you like on top of them
they get really upset
I'll top them literally yeah literally
okay yeah so every time when I'm having
a thing look
I didn't make you
we were made this way
so don't blame me because I think they
have that that's a lot that's logical
that usually doesn't work with them too
well yeah yeah
you have to you have to talk in
emotional ways sometimes for a woman to
actually understand well and I honestly
think that our emotions most of the time
are from the devil because it's like
sometimes you'll just get like really
really religious aren't you no it's
crazy it's not even it's not even like a
religion thing it's just like I don't
know when I when I think about things
like logically I do this is just well
the best a woman can right but like when
I just think these things through it's
like you know I I think most women like
in a breakup or whatever like this is
what we see women spite in breakups
today right when they when they take the
kids when they take the house they take
all this [__] and I'm like that that
obviously can't be from God right it's
got to be from the devil so it's like
women like I think the devil literally
uses women to abuse the men because
that's the way the devil can get to the
men and that's why you see see all these
like statues where they're like like I
saw that statue in New York of the woman
holding the man's head like that it's
like and even like there was a Medusa
there's some tribe in India where
literally yeah there was um this tribe
in India where literally they would
sacrifice men to the like Kali the god
goddess Kali and you'll see these like
um things like reiterated in the
magazines and like just in a modern day
like thing like I don't know symbolism
whatever but like that tribe was known
for being really violent and they
sacrificed men other men would go get
the simps right would go get the other
men and sacrifice the men to the goddess
Kali
yeah and I just I think it's yeah and I
because I just think of like the
angriest I've been in my life and it's
like weird it's like something's like
over you like you're so mad and so it's
like that can't be from God that's gotta
be from the devil and as a woman you
just kind of have to know like just wait
it'll pass it'll go away like don't yeah
um
when it comes to you and your
relationships do you follow a lot of the
same advice that you're actually giving
people when they listen to you I do I do
but you're not a hypocrite but well I
mean sometimes hell yeah sometimes like
sometimes I get mad you know it's like
you know I'm human I I don't think I'm
like the perfect example of a feminine
woman no I wish I was but at the end of
the day I was I was an athlete like I
spent most of my life in a gym and you
know I do the best I can but again I
just think it's like a dangerous
territory when we can't even acknowledge
the idea like as a man like you know
most men can say hey take care of all
the bills but some guys still have their
woman work part-time but they can say
hey taking care of all the bills is the
ideal they can say being in the best
shape fighting being strong that's the
ideal even if sometimes you know maybe
they got a beer belly maybe they're not
like men can at least acknowledge like
what the ideal is in general like
there's some iffyness women it's like we
can't even acknowledge the idea with
outgoing viral like to say you know you
know I'm not a virgin but like I think a
virgin is the ideal I think getting
married younger is the ideal it's like
you know
um but I don't understand why as women
we can't acknowledge what the ideal is
and try to work our way to it is it well
I mean most people probably have
different ideals though
well I think we live in la la land I
think like for women women definitely
living alone yeah you know I generally
we're just dummies
100 Years of propaganda brainwashing us
um you know people may like men may have
slightly different ideals but I think
the the core is still the same protect
your woman provide for your woman but we
can't even say as women the ideal is a
virgin like how crazy is that that's
like the one thing that was required for
marriage and we can't even agree we
can't even say look ladies I know none
of us waited all right but that's that's
what we should have did like we have
grown I just saw grown like 45 50 year
old women
um giving their advice to like younger
women on Tick Tock and they all said to
date around that's what they all said 45
year old yes yes this is the older women
don't help us and that's why it's like
we can't even get advice from the wives
because we have like we have such a
generation of shitty wives the the women
between the ages of like 40 and like 55
ish they might have stayed married or
been married for a while but they were
not good wives they they had the
propaganda like the really heavy
propaganda campaign in the 70s and the
80s they're not they're not good wives
and most of us really don't have much we
can learn from them unfortunately most
of them went to college most of them if
you say hey because this is where you
can really see it where like a woman's
head space is at do you obey your
husband and you know those women most of
them don't say yes they say no should a
woman obey your husband if he's a broke
ass [__]
uh if that's who she picked
unfortunately you know I I believe in
you know what what what what if she
picked a a person who showed a lot of
potential but when she got to know him
he was actually lying about I mean I'm
I'm Catholic well he was lying I think
we can actually get there's a lot of men
out there who pretend to be rich who
pretend to actually have things they
don't and then the women find out and
they're like oh okay well I mean I mean
I guess what is broke right is this
unemployed you didn't notice he was
unemployed because the average man makes
45 000 a year and he goes up to 70 000
that's average the average woman
remember it's not like we you know we're
not we're not on a like it's kind of
like get off your high horse like the
average woman isn't a virgin the average
woman's overweight and yet you're
demanding all these crazy things you
know
um so the average 90 of women have been
on birth control our fertility's
probably [__] up her hormones are
probably what about the men who were
actually telling their women to take
these damn pills
um I mean I don't think they should you
know I'm I'm not like but I'm Catholic
so I'm not the you know they'll be like
a pearls you know I'm not the best
Catholic but I but I am Catholic I am
Jewish I haven't been in Temple in 10
years but but it's like you know
marriage is supposed to be for richer
for poor for better for worse and
sickness and in health and like I I do
believe when you take those vows you're
not supposed to get divorced it is so if
a man cheats on a woman should she stay
with him yeah sorry like am I I don't
think he should cheat but you know I I
think again you know we have to get off
our high horses like come on you weren't
a virgin on your wedding day you could
have we could have picked monogamy at 21
and gotten married we didn't pick
monogamy
you think it's okay for a man to cheat
around and possibly bring STD back as
well no I don't I don't think it's okay
I don't think he should do that but but
if he if he does do that you're staying
by him side good okay well what are you
gonna do with the [__] STD on The
Dating Market you might as well stay at
that point
like no like what are you gonna you know
what I mean like now you're gonna go
back out there with an STD that's better
personally I probably sweat the person's
throat yeah that's just me well and I'm
not advocating for cheating but what I'm
saying is like you know let's what if we
accounted uh getting attention from
other men as cheating
like what if we accounted flirting with
another man as cheat because attention
is to women is the sexist men we cannot
live without attention men can't live
without sex so you know what if we
counted flirting with the personal
trainer what if we counted answering a
DM from someone else what if we counted
even just posting a selfie on Instagram
to make sure that personal trainer is a
woman
it's a prevention
sure you don't put those people in those
situations I agree with you but my whole
point is like a lot of times women will
be like oh he's the devil he cheated
it's just horrible and we allow women to
make such victims of ourselves just
being like oh you have such a poor you
poor thing he's just evil when it's like
okay you never cheated really like you
never flirted with someone else you
never you're you're into cheating I I
yeah I think for a woman yeah accepting
attention from another guy is cheating I
I don't think it is as much for a guy
yeah so I don't think unless a woman
Builds an emotional bond with another
person or she's lucky another person I
don't I don't see that okay so let's
let's take emotional bonds usually women
nowadays have like like I honestly think
women nowadays aren't even monogamous
because they usually have two or three
guy friends even in America like we're
in a society where we can't tell the
difference between wives and single
women you know in normal like you could
kind of tell the difference the women
would roll like the single women would
have the shorts skirt and then they get
married they put it away now you can't
even tell the difference so if we're
gonna count dressing provocatively less
seeking attention from other men the
same way like if a guy flirted with the
waitress you would be mad but women can
dress half naked which is clearly asking
for attention and nobody cares and so my
my whole point is like you know make
sure your side is clean before you start
whining about what the men are doing and
I think for 90 of women today to say you
never crossed the line ever when you
were married I think it's a bit silly to
throw away the whole marriage when women
have a lot harder time remarrying right
instead of figuring a way to work it out
and marriage is supposed to be about
forgiveness you know
um in astrology uh one thing I realize
is there's some signs that we'll put up
with cheating and there's some signs
don't so take notes guys uh I'm gonna
put this out there if a woman is born in
a goat year she'll put up with cheating
she will literally put up with people
cheating and I'm gonna give you an
example Anna Nicole Smith
everyone knows who that [__] is she
married a 90 year old billionaire and by
the way Anna Nicole Smith is born on the
28th she did get that bag didn't she but
the fact of the matter is you know when
when you look at these women and you
look at everything they're doing
um I I kind of disagree with what you
said I don't think people should be
cheating but if you're gonna go that
route
learn numerology astrology first of all
if you cheat on a rooster
it doesn't matter if you're a
millionaire it doesn't matter if you're
flat broke they'll cut you okay uh
Lauren Bobbitt I think the one who cut
off her dudes thingy that was she was
born in the rooster year but if you look
at other signs like goats
again as long as the man is providing
money and giving them a luxury lifestyle
they'll put up with it
there's certain things people have to
understand and this is why I keep
telling people knowledge is power think
of all the people in this world who are
putting up with garbage
you don't have to do it you just have to
put understand how to learn this
knowledge and apply it it's not just
about knowing things it's actually about
applying things in everyday life you
know um
when I look at a guy like Mr Beast
um I personally believe that he was put
on because I look at the TR uh his
little logo pink blue and white and I
look at the transgender [__] uh flag pink
blue and what I think at some point down
the line do cut a deal because he has no
Charisma and he's the top guy out there
but
the numerology tells me he's a three
life path and three is the number of
communication communication starts with
C threes or a letter zerk is a three you
know uh Rolo's a three sartains a three
uh uh a whole bunch of people out there
who basically are three life pads run
they're freaking Mouse I mean even the
past Rush Limbaugh people know who he
was yeah Howard Stern and Rush Limbaugh
are born on the same exact day the two
people who are supposedly the kings of
all media before you know people with
Pro took over and all this internet
stuff they were the kings of all media
they were born on the same day the 12
one and two is three so when you look at
stuff like that you start understanding
okay this is making sense why people are
a certain way but it doesn't just stop
there
there is people have to learn this stuff
I'm just telling you I just look at all
these people with all these problems and
I'm like God damn
[__] smart as hell because I figured
all this stuff out I never had these
problems I mean listen my girl was damn
near a virgin okay I didn't have these
problems as you guys did I I don't even
I I've been going on trips for 10 years
and I leave for a week two weeks do
business make money for the family
I don't ever worry that my girl is
cheating on me ever and she knows I'm
not [__] doing anything because I'm
not about that life
some people are
you know um some people like the Tates
they're tigers
tigers live their lives like those two
they're supposed you know being all
Alpha oh masculine halfway a bodybuilder
a freaking fighter this is what tigers
do and if you're gonna be with the tiger
don't expect them to be faithful that
that's just the bottom line
some signs will be faithful to the
freaking End roosters are oh so [__]
what oh so so loyal and I married a
rooster partly because of it
this is the stuff people have to
understand and if you do that let's just
gets so much more simple I have problems
with everyone else but not those type of
problems you know what I'm saying
um Malik
I want to change gears for the last uh
20 minutes that we have here and I want
to get a little bit more political
um what role do you believe your brother
right now has
in the Democratic Party
do you believe he's still a shot caller
or not
I think he is yeah he's still a shot
caller he has a lot of influence and my
thing is that whatever he says is what
goes
when I look at uh president Trump
um there's a long list of people who
worked for him
a lot of them unjustly
got you know hit with subpoenas got hit
with indictments some of them went to
prison and again this is all political I
get that
there's not one person who worked for
your brother who got locked up
not one
now we know your brother's corrupt as
hell surrender sir lindra Fast and the
Furious the money sent to Iran he sent
his brother sent 1.5 billion dollars in
unmarked bills to Iran why do you think
someone like that would do something
like that bro
I got no idea because they're cleaning
money because see in America we have
laws here and it's very very difficult
for politicians to steal money but do
you know why the politicians are so
benevolent with your money and your
money and my money because when they
send it overseas those laws aren't there
anymore so basically
um his brother sent all that money to
Iran guess who Iran kicked back some of
that money to
Barack Hussein Obama think about this
way uh there was a war in Afghanistan
for 20 years 20 years they pulled out
August
2012. they pulled out no I'm sorry 2021
they pulled out within six months
there's a warrant
why because one money laundering
operation came to an end they need to
start a new one in
all these politicians are dirty as hell
every single one of them and I I and
again I voted for Trump in two six I I
didn't vote for him because I'm a felon
and I'm not allowed to vote but I
convinced thousands about thousands of
people to vote for Trump in 216 and 220
but guess what
can't do it in 2024
I can't do it the wrong year exactly
because of what I believe in Donald J
Trump is born 1946 the year the dog
if he becomes president 2024 that's his
enemy year
that's not good that's not good so now
I'm in a very difficult position because
obviously I want to vote for the
conservative
and the others you know side is bunch of
pedophiles and a whole bunch of other
nonsense but I know what's gonna happen
Trump goes in office same thing that
happened with George W Bush George W
bush came to power in 2000 that was a
dragon year and he's born the same year
As Trump 1946. under his watch The Great
Recession under his watch 911 his
presidency was a complete freaking
failure
complete freaking failure we have an
Obama because of a bush
and we had a Donald Trump because of
Obama
the only way Republicans can actually
defeat this
basically Coalition of actuals feminists
a whole bunch of other [__] the only
way it's gonna happen
if we do it on a state level
state by state by state they can't do it
on a federal level they have to do it at
the state level they have to pass the
laws in every single state that says we
will check every single vote not once
not twice we have something called
blockchain we have something called
crypto right now why can't we vote the
same way
there's too many dead people voting and
the problem is all these bastards are
always voting for the Democratic party
right every single time it goes every
time there's a cheating scandal anytime
there's some kind of dead person voting
it's always going for Democrats what are
conservatives cheat back I I I've been
trying to figure that out for a long
time that's our problem we're too like
moral and principles I I I'm done with
that I used to believe that stuff 15
years ago oh no it doesn't matter what
they did we got to be better than them I
don't believe that [__] at all anymore
that I I was brainwashed to believe that
I don't believe that [__] at all anymore
if they're playing with fire then you're
playing with fire they bring out a knife
you bring out a bigger [__] knife you
have to get it to the point like a CIA
agent once told me you kill one of mine
I'm taking a [__] 100 of yours
that's how it has to be because when you
project power
you don't have to use it uh you know uh
look at a guy uh like his bodyguard
that's a big boy that's a big boy you
think anyone's coming up to him and
saying yo get the [__] out of my way no
one's gonna say [__] to him and it
doesn't even matter if he can fight he's
intimidating so by the fact of the fact
that he's intimidating
that itself is strength because people
won't test you and that's why America
must remain the superpower in the world
it has to happen because I'm gonna I'm
really really worried that my kids and
grandkids will grow up under CCP role
that is one of the most frightening
things Chinese Communist party I'm very
very concerned because to me that is the
greatest evil
after feminism on the planet right now
it was the CCP these people
they own everything they want people to
have social credit scores like for
instance if you're in China and you have
a bad social credit score you can't go
in a store to buy food
this is to the point they want to bring
it here they want that Society here and
Communists and socialists always say the
same [__] [__] over and over you
bring up the case of the Soviet Union
that failed you bring up the case of
Venezuela that failed you bring up all
of these cases and these these freaking
morons will keep telling you oh but it
wasn't done correctly socialism works
but it wasn't done correctly Communism
works it wasn't done correctly I'm going
to tell you right now one of my heroes
in life is General Franco you ever hear
of that guy you ever hear of General
Franco he was in Spain yes and I've
never been in Spain so why would he be
my hero because he [__] put communist
in the [__] ground
Anyone who puts communist in the ground
I [__] love you because when it comes
down to it I know what communism is
because my dad escaped communist and he
came here and he had a conversation with
me when I was eight nine years old he
told me Gary
I ran away from the Communists
you won't be able to run there's nowhere
else to run he told me that in the 80s
and he was not an educated man but he
was a very very smart man
and you know when my dad passed he
didn't leave me any money
we we were middle class to below or
above at some point but we're always
moving like this
um
but I thank him every single day
I start thanking them once I start
getting some sense because
he came to this country
he came to America he gave me the
opportunity
to be in the greatest country on Earth
and because I had the opportunity I
became a freaking millionaire
I would not have done this in any other
country on Earth
flat out
I love this country
but this country needs to be saved
because if if it's not saved within the
next decade it's going to be too far
gone
it's gonna be too far gone and I really
don't know what to do at that point it
was like brute says at that point
Society is gonna destroy itself and then
we're gonna go through that same cycle
of strong men coming from tough times
and they build their kids up and all of
a sudden these kids become soft and the
whole cycle repeats repeats one thing I
always do I have a 10 year old and a
four-year-old
I don't allow my boys to cry
I do not allow it if they want to scream
if they want to get mad cool you know
I'll have a nice talk with them like yo
chill out cool but if they start crying
I get in their [__] face don't
[__] cry do not cry and I recommend
every single dad out there does the same
thing to your kids do not allow them to
cry because you know if you're a woman
and you cry
people gonna help you people are gonna
come they're gonna feel sorry for you
they're going to want to help you men
are going to want to help you women are
going to want to help you you see a man
crying
they've done that social experiment Like
a Man versus a woman crying in public
they did not give a [__] no one gives a
[__] and that's why I want these kids to
understand
get that solved feminism bait as [__]
out
just get rid of it because when they
grow up
and you're not around anymore
you can't have them being soft a woman
will tear a soft Man Apart quicker than
a [__] criminal just like you said
they will take advantage of them and
they would [__] destroy him
um
I
my organization is gg33 I basically run
a group about 3 000 people
85 percent of my students are men
and I always make sure it's about around
that ratio
and the reason I do that is because if
you have too many women in one group
they're gonna start fighting they're
gonna start hating each other here's the
thing about men and Malik correct me if
you think I'm wrong
no person will want
um want anything but the best for their
son
if you as a father you want your son to
do better than you you as a father you
want your son to do the stuff that you
did not accomplish in life
a woman and uh her daughter
I've seen a little bit different
I've actually seen
mothers be jealous of their daughters
because they're better looking than they
are
yeah it's disgusting that there's a ton
of moms that are jealous of their
daughters that's really cool it's
disgusting it is absolutely disgusting
because they're single
Ah that's why they're not meant to be
like they're supposed to have the man
they want's attention
so either they're not with the man they
want and they're looking
or they're already
or they couldn't keep him
whatever it is and now they're like
think about it um you have a daughter at
20. now 40 year old and 20 year old are
in the same Club
you cannot tell that's a crazy thing you
can't you know you're supposed to one's
a little more used up though but that's
the crazy thing like you used to be able
to tell the difference in the way they
dressed between a 40 year old and a 20
year old I can't tell anymore no they
dress exactly the same I mean you can
you can tell the wrinkles you know what
I mean but but they look exactly the
same it's crazy father time is
undefeated
absolutely undefeated I had a question
why do women have this fascination with
their lips that
I see a lot of women now with these
thick lips
they put Botox
yeah what is that because I'm noticing
that happening and mostly these women
who have money remember women were
dummies so if they just yeah if they
just Market us anything we'll buy it so
they got they've marketed uh lip filler
dust and we bought it
I find that unattractive I know I find
breast implants unattractive yet you
have a whole bunch of women who do them
I mean this is why I keep telling people
Pearl they s these red pill guys say
these women are crazy they keep saying
oh yo these [__] are out there
[__] mind I agree with them but then
they tell them to get breast implants
then they tell them to take birth
control pills what the [__] how is that
helping the situation at all who tells
them to get breasts there's quite a few
red pill guys that you know tell people
to women to enhance themselves any way
possible I mean hell if you're Brazilian
they're gonna tell you to put something
in your butt yeah I mean there's Kanye
West's mom mother died
Kanye West's mother died because of
plastic surgery you know I'll say this
um
there's different strategies that women
use to attract different types of guys
and unfortunately the the guys that
women we tend to go for When We're Young
are the rappers the Ballers the all that
like it's just a bad boys yeah I mean
yeah sort of and so because of that you
know they're marketing for the look and
those guys typically aren't seeking
long-term mates typically I mean are
those guys known for being family men in
general the rapper is the ball right so
so what are they marketing themselves to
those guys they want to get with what in
this Society is the top guys which is
unfortunate like we're not you know as
women we want what's trendy what's cool
and that's what we see right even though
let's be honest the businessmen have way
more power than any of those guys but
you know we're we're dummies right so so
because that's in the media that's we
Market ourselves for uh we're about to
start wrapping this up Pearl give us red
flags that guys can look for in women
um that's just kind of traversal I think
tattoos uh personally
um I think
a lot of
I mean being fat obviously there's no
discipline